[Music]
so
you're listening to radio sputnik
telling the untold
welcome to the open university of the
airwaves
with george callaway only on sputnik
radio
i haven't slept for 48 hours so this
episode might be even more
rock and roll than normal as a million
of you on twitter
already know that's because in the early
hours of yesterday morning
my good wife gave birth to our third my
sixth child it was very grueling indeed
but
i'm over it at least well enough to
present
this evening's show in the final hour
we'll be unveiling the baby's name
and our very first picture show to the
great audience of the mother
of all talk shows about between now
and then we'll be dealing with deadly
serious stuff and i
emphasize deadly in the week of the
anniversary 75th
of the explosions at hiroshima and
nagasaki a conventional
explosion in the port of beirut
dealt devastation not seen for a very
long time
even in the troubled city the capital of
lebanon uh billions of dollars worth of
damage
hundreds of people dead thousands of
people
maimed and every house flattened but the
political
implications may be even more
significant
than all of that we'll be talking about
coronavirus
about donald trump about joe biden and
about the
epidemic of fatherlessness
in britain and indeed across most of the
western world
but the main burden of my remarks will
be
on lebanon which i first entered as a
very young man more than
40 years ago it opened the door to the
arab world for me
it's right here in my heart and i
can feel their pain and shall express it
stay tuned
and fasten your seat belts this is rock
and roll radio
with pictures
radio sputnik we speak your language
the mother of all talk shows the only
education
you can get for free
[Music]
george galloway this
is radio sputnik
and this is london but coming to you of
course
all over the world thanks to the wonders
of the internet
and sputniknews.com we are
of course on fm in the washington dc
area
105.5 are the magic numbers there and on
am from coast to coast right across the
united states of america
you can listen worldwide on
sputniknews.com
but as hundreds of thousands of you now
do
every week you can watch as well as
listen
if you are watching on facebook either
on my facebook page or on the multiple
rt facebook pages please please please
share share share it's very important
you tell
all of your friends on facebook that
this show
is broadcasting now now
we're also of course on youtube and
we are on twitter and even on
instagram we're even on one or two other
platforms of which i know
little but we now have a health warning
unlike the voice of america which
does exactly what it says on the tin i.e
speak for america unlike the bbc
so intimately connected to the state
that you
go to prison if you don't pay the state
their license fee even if you never
watch the bbc they can shell for free
and no health warning no label
stuck on their chest
but we on the other hand are speaking
truth to power we are
acting as we speak
we are providing pluralism
we are providing different voices
different takes
me and alex salmond on scotland for
example all kinds of people
are appearing on rt but now they will
have to wear
a badge on their chest
now it's a small badge to be sure but a
cloud
no bigger than a man's hand can be a
harbinger
of great storms to come and so
i've got my wrinkle in the back of the
car
just in case it's very important
that you follow my youtube
channel it's very important you
subscribe to it
it's very important that you visit my
website
georgegalloway.com i'm not saying
anything's imminent but we have to
be careful that we don't allow this
great
global university to be somehow censored
or somehow
closed down do you feel me good
now uh in 1977
along with my editor today that's how
long we have been
together i entered
the arab world through the portal of the
great city
of beirut the capital of lebanon i loved
it so much i stayed on
when the rest of them went home i lived
amongst the
debris and the damage from
many years of civil war which had
only temporarily lulled when i was
there so i know beirut in
dark days and fine i know it at peace
and i
know it at war the famous
legendary ingenuity and
indefatigability of the lebanese people
has allowed them to drag themselves off
the floor
many many times and rebuild this
jewel of the orient
of which beirut and lebanon represents
it's not just the beauty of the
countryside
where you can ski on the mountains in
the morning and water ski
in the mediterranean in the afternoon
both of which
i myself have done it's not just
uh the remarkable personality
of the lebanese people it is the fact
that it is a
fragile confessional cross-sectarian
community of people
which was set up by imperial powers
france about which more later which
divided lebanon
from its mother in
syria and made two states
of one piece of arab land a familiar
prescription uh which we have seen in
many
other pla places but never mind sykes
pico
the lebanese people have been making a
go of it
in the most extraordinary circumstances
for a very long time to be sure the
lebanese government all governments
in lebanon and across the arab world
are run by crooks to be sure
corruption is endemic in the lebanese
state
but just as the bumble bee according to
the
laws of aerodynamics cannot fly
its wings are too short its body too
heavy
according to the normal laws of politics
and economics
lebanon could not survive but survive
it has it has an extraordinary
political system which is one of the
main
problems for the vultures
that have landed literally in beirut
over the
last few days principle amongst them
little bonaparte macron whose own
streets
have been burning for over a year
his own security forces
leveling out atrocious violence
against his own people but he's landed
in beirut
as the savior the colonial power
returned but the problem for macron
and for president trump and all the
other vultures that are gathering
is that they cannot call for democracy
in lebanon and i'm going to explain why
because
i discovered in the last couple of days
a very large number of people
don't know why you see the president of
lebanon
has to be a christian according to
the constitution the prime minister
of lebanon has to be a sunni
muslim and the speaker of the parliament
the least important of these three
positions
has to be held by a shiite
muslim now the main problem with that
is that since that scheme was drawn up
the shiites have become perhaps they
always were
overwhelmingly the biggest community
in lebanon so the biggest community in
lebanon
gets the least important position in
the government and the christians
get the presidency and the sunnis get
the premiership
so if you had one man one woman one vote
in lebanon then said hassan nasrallah
would be
the president in a landslide actually
but hezbollah don't want political power
in lebanon they are the main defenders
of a political system that keeps them
in the least important political
position because they know
that to tamper with this extremely
fragile sectarian schema
risks all out civil war and the
total destruction of the country and
that's what they don't want so
trump and macron unlike in other places
cannot demand one man one woman one vote
for lebanon because that would lead to
the overwhelming victory
of the political force that they like
least
so what you have in lebanon is an
alliance between the shiite
blocs of amal
led by the speaker of the parliament
nabi beri
hezbollah and the christian
general general aoun
who is the president of the country now
you can imagine that that is a
powerful block and that's the problem
it's a powerful block defending lebanese
sovereignty
from those who would transgress against
it
it's a powerful block stopping the rise
of the very al-qaeda isis and
other islamist fundamentalists in
lebanon
that rose and rose and rose with western
support
in syria and so we're asking on the
poll right now will lebanon become the
next
a ukraine b hong kong
or c syria and syria is running away
with it 65
of the vote so far and that's the game
ladies and gentlemen
having failed to achieve regime
change in syria the syrian
arab army and people and their allies
having defeated isis and al-qaeda in
syria
they want to have another go in lebanon
and see if they can't take down both
lebanon
and syria with one bowling
ball do you get me that's what's going
on
in lebanon of course corruption of
course
crooks of course malfeasance and of
course above all
who left 2 700
tons of ammonium nitrate in a warehouse
in the port of beirut for
seven years who left it there
but just as importantly who brought it
there
whose ammonium nitrate was this
to whom was it being sent
the ship from which it was confiscated
was a moldovan registered
ship because of course moldova is a big
maritime power but the owners
of the ship were ukrainian
so we have a ukrainian ship registered
in moldova docking in beirut
2 700 tons of
one of the world's deadliest explosives
confiscated and left
in the warehouse in the port of
beirut big questions those aren't they
where was the destination of that
explosive why did it dock in
beirut my own theory
is this we'll test it with a real expert
in just a few minutes this explosive
material was intended for the rebels in
syria
it was destined for al qaeda and isis
it was part of the regime change
operation
in syria but it was intercepted
and taken off and then nobody did
anything about it but how did it
explode was it a fire
in a fireworks factory next to it
was it as donald trump said a bomb
an attack or was it
a pure industrial accident of
utterly devastating proportions
these are the questions that we'll be
discussing
with rania khalek my colleague
my friend who was there when it happened
we'll be talking to about the
aforementioned donald trump
we'll be talking about his putative
opponent joe biden i enter the word
putative
because the more i see him the less i
believe
that he is going to be the candidate
against trump in november i believe the
democrats are involved in one of the
most complex
political conspiracies in all
american history about which more
later i will also
be talking about the epidemic
of fatherlessness as the father of six
children
myself i'm well familiar with the
pitfalls of the
children's justice system of
the rights of fathers and of the
responsibility
of fathers fathers often have almost no
rights
and often take almost no responsibility
i'm in no doubt call me a social
conservative if you like
that a family without a father
is not going to function
as well as a family with a father
a child that grows up without a father's
influence is more likely to
go off the rails than one
who doesn't that's not of course to say
that single parent families
male or overwhelmingly more often female
don't bring up their children well that
would be absurd
some of the best families some of the
best
upbringings have been from
single parent households
but that being true does not negate my
point
that ying and yang mum and dad
is the best way we've found as a human
race
so far to raise children to bring up
families that's what i believe in any
case
and we'll be canvassing those points
with you
as well as with our expert guests in the
course
of the show and of course no show i'm
afraid
is complete in this year of 2020
without a discussion about the
coronavirus
which is now spiraling out of control
in many parts of the world and even in
some parts
of britain in aberdeen we have a new
lockdown
in greater manchester extended now to
preston
we have a new lockdown we have people in
there
10 scores of thousands cheek by jowl
on beaches in england right now
i don't know where they go to the toilet
by the way but then
that's just the kind of silly thing i
wonder
when i see them but my main question
when i see them is if you're not
maintaining social distance if anybody
on that beach has got the coronavirus
you have a very real chance of catching
it
just as the people in aberdeen did when
they went to a pub
innocently as they were entitled to do
just last week
and now the whole city and the whole
economy
is locked down we'll be talking too
about galen maxwell and jeffrey epstein
now i'm no stranger to
sexual deviancy i spent nearly 30 years
in parliament
which was full of it one of my
colleagues
was found dead with
satsuma in his mouth dangling from the
ceiling
whilst dressed in ladies lingerie
and i'm not making that up that's what
happened
to a conservative member of parliament a
grande of the world of business
journalism
when i was sitting in the house of
commons the scottish parliament is even
gayer they boast they are the
gayest of all parliaments anywhere in
the world
but it came nonetheless as a shock to me
because i remembered that prince
andrew's ex-wife fergie
came a cropper because she was sucking
somebody's toes and somebody caught her
on camera and suck one toe
you'll always be remembered as a tour
sucker
according to the papers now unsealed
in the united states of galen maxwell
prince andrew ii
was a tour sucker according to a young
girl then age
17 who had been illegally trafficked
in order to have her toes sucked by
prince andrew it's a family show so
we won't go any further than that but it
is
the mother of all talk shows
the tough questions are the most
powerful weapon we have
as long as you have questions we'll keep
asking
[Music]
radio sputnik telling the untold
comrade tired of being trapped in
mainstream media
join the revolution with mother of
all toxins has been instrumental
in making brain and heart of people
stronger
like kettlebell for nine don't be
brainwashed cc
an open mind to new way of thinking
[Music]
if you don't know how george will teach
you
if you want learn he will
make you speak to comrade galloway
if you think you are hard enough on the
mother
of all talk shoes
radio sputnik
the mother of all talk shows with george
galloway
the world is our classroom and you're
welcome to sit in
and join the seminar well the poll is
raging will lebanon become the next a
ukraine 19 b hong kong
16 percent c syria aportentis
65 you can vote now on my twitter feed
at george galloway 413 of you
have done so far now my friend and
colleague
rachel blevins journalist broadcaster
and rt america correspondent joins us
now
to talk all things americana and as
always rachel a very big welcome on the
mother of all talk shows now because you
are a delicate young lady i won't take
you down
all the byways of prince andrew and
his peccadillos i'll just ask you
briefly if you will before we get on to
even more important things
uh has guillain maxwell survived another
week
in an american penitentiary
you know george as far as we know she
has but we still have yet to see a mug
shot we've yet to see
any images of her being arrested or of
her being transferred from the prison
that she was supposedly taken to in new
hampshire
and then taken over to new york so that
still leaves a lot of questions if we
haven't seen anything
other than a court sketch has she been
arrested is she there
is it as they say that it is there's a
lot of questions surrounding that so
as far as the report they're saying they
say that she survived another week
but there still seem to be countless
questions surrounding her case
and now as all of these details come out
as there are more
documents that are released and unsealed
then we also have to take a look at the
us justice system and ask
why they've had this information for
years and have quite literally done
nothing with it
quite sure uh any other big names other
than prince andrew
uh particularly embarrassed by the
unsealed papers so far
well you know right now it's the u.s
justice system that should be
embarrassed by all of it but we know
we've talked a lot about prince andrew
we've talked about jean-luc pernell
leslie wexner big names like that that
have been
really associated with jeffrey epstein
but then all of a sudden those figures
just kind of went missing
whenever we were told that he went
missing as well and so it
does raise those questions of why you've
got you know an fbi and intelligence
community here in the united states that
is funded to the tune of nearly 63
billion dollars
every single year and yet they're not
able to stay on top of those names that
are regularly circulated around in the
media
and what did bill clinton first see in
the
multi-millionaire pervert jeffrey
epstein that's an excellent question you
know bill clinton is one of those whose
name was mentioned on epstein's flight
logs a number of times so we know that
he flew on his plane
we know that bill clinton has been
mentioned by epstein's victims and we
also know that he had meetings with
epstein while he was in the white house
and so
as to why there's not a lot more fanfare
surrounding that
i can't say but bill clinton definitely
has gotten up easy on this one so far
and yet donald trump is still sending
his love to galen maxwell what's that
all about
right you know it's been interesting to
see donald trump try to
almost distance himself a little bit by
saying oh he didn't know these people
even though he's been pictured with
these people
a number of times and even though he's
made a number of comments about jeffrey
epstein himself
saying that he likes girls a little on
the younger side well now trump is kind
of having to walk those comments back
and he's probably hoping that they don't
follow him all the way to the 2020
election
let's talk about that then um i saw a
picture of joe biden
on a bike i don't know if he knew he was
on a bike i'm certain he didn't know
where he was going but this is a clear
attempt to
try and halt the now
majority feeling in the united states
according to the opinion polls uh that
uh
that joe biden is approaching if not
already in a state of senility
it does seem that way and you know i saw
that same video of biden he got out of
his basement it appears he was riding on
a bike
and a reporter on the sidelines was
asking him who is your vice presidential
pick and he pointed out the reporter and
he said you
and then his campaign had to come out
and walk it back and say no no he didn't
actually mean that he was just
kidding but it does bring up the fact
that there's so much we still don't know
i mean we're talking about a buy in
ticket for the democratic party
and we don't even know who the other
half of that ticket is we're talking
about debates hopefully happening but
you know the biden campaign has really
distanced themselves from that
and it seems like every single week now
we get some new sun bite of him and some
ridiculous interview
making comments that his campaign is
having to come back and apologize for
yeah i mean i saw some video that
they're they're leading him around uh
like a child
uh and hurrying him on so that he
doesn't say too much
to anyone but that can't possibly last
as
a strategy until november and he
himself has said he looks forward to the
debates
uh with uh president trump so it's going
to be difficult for them now
to walk that back uh it would be like
watching
mike tyson fighting a small child
uh to see donald trump against joe biden
in his current state wouldn't it
yeah it definitely seems like if we do
get an in-person debate or
even a virtual debate for that matter it
would definitely be something that would
be much more of a reality or
entertainment show
than actually two legitimate
presidential candidates who are arguing
back and forth
about policies and about what they're
going to try to bring to the united
states over the next four years
well biden might well be entering
uh senility but donald trump
seems to me more and more unhinged uh
some of the statements that he's making
uh and his walk out today uh
from uh from a press conference
literally just waving and walking
off the stage there's good grounds for
saying
that he might actually not make it
either
i mean the if you add the mental state
of these two candidates together you
don't get
gerald ford yeah and you know it's crazy
to think that
we're talking about the two richest
political parties in the united states
and yet
these are the two candidates that they
have to offer right here you know when
it comes to donald trump this has
certainly been his race to lose whenever
it comes to this election
and yet when we're at a time when he
could really be stepping up he seems to
kind of be backing down in a lot of ways
especially when you're talking about the
fact that
the united states has just now hit 5
million coronavirus cases a world record
and yet trump came out this week and he
said that he
wanted to bring some executive actions
he wanted
to stand up for those americans who are
facing eviction or who are struggling to
pay
their loans because of unemployment and
yet he's gotten a lot of backlash
from that from people saying well it's
easy for him to talk
and to say that he wants to bring those
executive actions but to
actually put those actions into place
that's going to be another thing coming
so what's your feeling about it uh
rachel
um i know what the polls say they
show biden consistently ahead
by about 10 points uh less in the swing
states
um if you are calling it now
is it biden you think well when looking
back at 2016 you know donald trump was
consistently behind hillary clinton
whenever it came to the polls they said
that there was no chance of him winning
and then he managed to win it anyway but
we also have to remember when looking
back at 2016
the united states saw the lowest voter
turnout in
20 years because nearly half of
americans
said that they would rather just stay
home and not vote at all than to have to
go and vote
for two of the most unpopular candidates
in us history now we've replaced hillary
clinton with joe biden
but at the same time it seems like we're
right back in that same place where we
have two
unpopular candidates that no one really
wants to vote for
so i think whenever it comes down to
this election i think it's going to be
really close but it could still be trump
taking it away
just as long as he you know gets those
coronavirus cases down
and gets the economy back into some
short sort of shape that people are
actually happy with
it could still be his race so finally
and i'm grateful for your time
the 64 000 question therefore
is who is biden's vice presidential
pick you know i don't even know if he
knows at this point you know they've
said that it may be kamala harris who is
a senator who was initially running for
the democratic nomination herself
but she got a lot of backlash from her
record as a prosecutor
and from the fact that she specifically
targeted poor minorities in her
area we've also heard people talk about
susan rice who was president obama's
national security advisor
but of course she was embedded right
there in all of his administration's
foreign policy decisions
and so basically what they've guaranteed
is to say that they're not going to say
it just yet whenever it comes to the
vice presidential pick
but it will certainly be someone who is
going to stay within that establishment
and is going to toe the party line no
matter what
even if joe biden doesn't make it that
far rachel blevins as always big thanks
for joining us on the mother of all talk
shows thank you
uh paul will lebanon become the next
ukraine
the next hong kong or the next syria you
can vote now
on my twitter feed i'm being flooded
with the paperwork sean
says in response to the poll every
country that america has touched in the
middle east
has turned into another syria and on
twitter
mr s says moats needs to be available
live to everyone on tv instead of the
stuff on the bbc news channel
fortunately i have youtube hi george
thank you mr s
glenis says congratulations to you all
and welcome to your new baby girl lovely
news thank you glennis you'll see her
picture
and the name uh later in the show
phil says lebanon battered and beaten
economically
and physically for so many years this
catastrophe is very convenient
and it's heartbreaking and by email matt
says here in portugal
there are shops and bars with anti-viral
cash machines these are tills into which
money is inserted
and the change dispensed without any
human contact or manipulation
do you have anything similar in england
i don't know actually maybe someone can
tell me that
youtube levi says dr ranjit
did a superb stream the other day
honestly the man
is a legend he is indeed and peace for
all says
hope those victims of royal toe sucking
had athletes foot and richard says
george i'm strapped in for a bumpy
ride and paul says i missed my weekly
smile
with burning city to burning city i
thought it was unkind
paul and on facebook june says
congratulations best wishes to you and
your family
on your new arrival you make me even
more proud
to be scottish if indeed that is
possible thank you
lovely june uh thanks for that
uh i've got a lot of name suggestions
coming in i'll uh
better leave them till later eve in
idaho
is on the line now go ahead eve
hello george uh today i have a question
for you uh the you know the epstein
we know about the sex trafficking the
rape and
all that aspect we also believe that he
was working
for the mossad but we don't have any
proof for it
but but i would like because i think you
know that part very well
i would like you to shed some light on
the arm trafficking
you know he began his carrier epstein
with arm trust arm trafficker on arm
trafficking
and i would like you to to speak about
that i i can't because i i don't know
about it so
if you do please tell us eve
oh no i thought you named because your
name was
was referred many times in a in an
interview
they had um
they had an interview of somebody who
knew um
i think are you confusing are you
confusing with maxwell
i did uh reveal that robert maxwell
galen's father
had been involved in arms trafficking
but i don't know anything about epstein
and arms trafficking i do know that his
rise and rise
is completely inexplicable under
educated
under achieving and becoming a
billionaire with
other people's money living in the
largest townhouse in manhattan
which he purchased for one single dollar
evading prosecution for years
whilst randomly
committing sex crimes against children
whilst being uninterrupted
in the course of that criminality by the
law enforcement agencies
and then when in florida the law began
to
crank into action down
came the hand from washington to
stay uh the investigations and possible
prosecutions i'm absolutely certain
that the reason all these powerful
political men
were drawn into the orbit
of epstein was so that they could be
filmed in compromising situations and
blackmailed
either for money or for political uh
favors all of that i'm sure of eve
but i don't know anything about him
being an arms trafficker
there was no relation between um between
uh
eptine and khashoggi i don't know if
he's the one
who was butchered recently or if it was
the maybe
the one maybe maybe if you get any
further particulars let us
have them if anyone knows of any
connection
between epstein and khashoggi uh
please let me know uh our phone number
is oh two o seven seven nine eight two
two five
five uh and from the u.s zero zero
one seven five seven seven four four
four four eight zero
now my short for rt this week
was on beirut here it is
whatever whoever was responsible for
what happened in beirut
has managed to push a country already on
the edge
over the cliff into the pit of
catastrophe
[Music]
beirut was the portal through which i
myself
entered the arab world more than 40
years
ago i fell in love with it at first
sight
as anyone who's ever been there will
tell you
the same lebanon is a simply magical
place
whereas the brochures used to say you
could ski in the mountains in the
morning and water ski
in the mediterranean in the afternoon
that was how it was packaged of course
the reality
of many hundreds of thousands of people
living in palestinian refugee camps or
living
in poverty as an oppressed sect
in lebanon unseen unnoticed
and certainly not acknowledged for
decades
has all changed lebanon by virtue of
its very creation by the sykes pico
agreement its division from its
motherland
in syria has always been
a place of multiple crises crisscrossing
the confessional and sectarian nature
of the country and yet despite the civil
war
despite the crises the legendary
fortitude and
ingenuity of the lebanese people
allowed them to drag themselves out of
the pit
of 1970s civil war and rebuild that
magical place
a magnet for travelers from all over the
world not least
travelers from the arabian gulf and from
other arab countries three billion
dollars worth of devastation
in an instant when the port the harbor
of beirut blew up as far as we know
by accident though who can tell in that
part
of the world three billion dollars
a hundred dead and thousands injured
already collapsing hospitals due to
economic crises have now been
overwhelmed by the sheer
scale of the casualty list
but the explosion in beirut is merely
the proximate cause
of this catastrophic crisis
lebanon was already in severe trouble
as a result of sanctions our old friend
sanctions again the sanctions against
syria have been
extended into lebanon as the united
states
empire tries to reconfigure
political power in lebanon but there are
some facts
that simply will not shift hezbollah
the majority shiite political party
has overwhelming support from the
overwhelmingly
most numerous section of the lebanese
population
their alliance with the legendary
christian
military officer now president general
aaron
makes them a powerful coalition
that simply cannot be wished away
those who want to wish them a way have
persuaded the united states
administration that lebanon is an enemy
the price
and even availability of staples will
now be
threatened in a potentially deadly way
by the utter devastation of the port
through which almost everything that
lebanon eats
comes in if the united states had
any sense it would now call off the war
against lebanon it would flood lebanon
with humanitarian aid
and financial credits it would bail out
lebanon
and gain the honor that they
long ago lost gain to the hearts and
minds of the people
not just in lebanon but throughout the
arab world where lebanon
is a national treasure but i'm not sure
that the united states
has a heart or even a head
certainly a head with a brain in it it's
likely that attempts will be made
to try and blame others for the
catastrophe which has occurred
donald trump said from the podium that
his great generals had told them
that the catastrophe was caused by an
attack
by a bomb that's not what the lebanese
government say but
inquiries are at an early stage
it would be hardly any surprise
if bomb and attack it was after all
israel has been attacking lebanon almost
every day
certainly every week for as long as i've
been going there that's
more than 40 years it might not be
any of the parties involved in the
complicated political situation
in lebanon it could be someone else
entirely we'll have to wait and see what
is
harvested by the inquiry now underway
but if history is anything to go by
the rumor mill will make the judgment
long before the
inquiry report is published lebanon's
economic
catastrophe and its political crises
are about to get much worse
as for the people of the world i think
our responsibility is clear the whole
world
has to rise up now and demand that we
save
lebanon a precious jewel of the orient
have something to say do you disagree
with george
then call us now and give us your view
now if you're watching on facebook
please right now
share share share with all of your
friends
because we're being algorithmically s
squeezed in all kinds of places do you
get me
so please now if you're on facebook
share with your
friends let's take a quote from simon
in south ribble go ahead simon
hello george nice to hear from you what
would you like to say
well first of all i'd just like to thank
foreign just to congratulate you for
myself and my wife on the
birth of your little girl thank you
simon there's life in
us all dogs yet
yeah really i'd say what i'm drinking
for was you probably heard that there's
a lockdown in preston
yes um well i mean it's just a soundbar
to be honest with you that's out on the
news because
there's absolutely no way that it's a
locked down um i was driving through
fellaini south level which isn't under
lockdown we're just to the south of the
river so we haven't come under that
lockdown
yet but i was driving through preston
yesterday evening and all the pubs are
open
and bouncers are outside letting people
in just as it would normally everyone's
outside bagging it little close groups
coupling
well not a couple of meters apart like
you know three or four people within
one or two meters like they would
normally be nothing was going on
the police are walking around six inches
apart no fed shields on
uh no face masks there's it really isn't
a lockdown george
it's typical isn't it assignment isn't
that where we've been
throughout in this whole thing things
are called things that they
actually aren't uh things are introduced
too
slowly and lifted too quickly uh
the uh two of my kids are in greater
manchester but
their area is not under lockdown so
their cafes and pubs
and so on are uh open as normal
or the new normal and as you describe it
now
preston doesn't sound like it is
actually under lockdown
at all no no it's not it's not and to be
honest with you i mean i feel sorry for
you know the authorities i mean although
although i absolutely hate the tories
you know i feel sorry for the position
that boris is in because
it's an absolutely impossible position
to be in
and i don't know what the answer is i
don't think anyone knows what the answer
is
and but saying there's a lot down and
then there isn't
surely that just doesn't help no listen
great call simon
love to the wife also thank you for your
good wishes
brian is in glasgow on the issue of
father's rights go ahead go ahead brian
hi george hey and congratulations young
man
thank you thank you so much uh
yeah george i i i tried to sort of get
people to understand when you mentioned
fatherlessness i think this if you
discuss it correctly would be historic
and it's the biggest elephant
in the room and this idea when we talk
about the right of fatherhood
and somehow the right of men or the
fathers
it's about something that automatically
implies
a scenario involving three people a man
a woman and a child and fatherhood
roughly 150 years ago lost its legal
standing and the implications of that
are still being avoided by
parliamentarians i can attest to this
personally i in my own case my own
journey
is actually part infinitely part of the
reason why there's a 2006 family law
scotland act
yet that act does not comply with echr
because it applies gender a protected
status
and whether the parent is married to
decide
blanket that those persons will not
enjoy
an echr right to family life if they're
not married
if they're not married that's as
irrelevant
as the point the law sees that is
irrelevant being married or not married
has
no bearing in law to whether someone
should have access
or not to their child well take a look
the way i look at it is this it's the
child that has the right
to a father and for
far too many uh people
including the judges are making
decisions
uh that deprive the child of that right
to uh having a father in the uh
sorry i apologize 20 years ago attrition
dragged to a court to try and get access
to my own child
and therefore reading case law supreme
case law
i cannot tell you it's actually
automatic that judges may make decisions
that outside look like they have
just discounted the father because it's
built into the law
and if they are pressed with a certain
amount of
you and i did not classes against
interest in the child
they're on a time limit this child
supposed to go on its family life they
are forced
but they don't see it that way it's just
a law but the fact is
that if you sit down a judge or indeed
an ex-legislator
or a legislator currently and you're an
ex-legislator
and ask them to explain how it is you
can deny someone
because of their gender and their model
status a
either a child in question all that [ __ ]
parent
the same rights everyone else you cannot
apply that to the test
and come up with an answer in other
words use evolve fraudulently
took us into a position in law that is
clearly incompatible
with the law it sits in hence why i'm
trying to say
we are all being denied their basic
human rights by the legislator
not one legal document sets anywhere
that would give a legal proof that would
be peer reviewable
that explains how compliance was
achieved with regard to this law
it's a legal fraud well look i'll tell
you what uh
brian uh we've got coming up later
michael
likovich who's director of
communications at families
need fathers so that's in the second
hour
stay tuned for that thanks very much
indeed
for the call guy who's almost a legend
in stockholm trent good to hear from you
again guy
yeah i i good evening george and first
of all congratulations on
thank you and your daughter and you and
i will hope everything goes well
um but i'm actually calling for
condolences and sympathy to the
hundreds who've lost their lives and the
injured in beirut
uh but the call i'm making is that
when the news story broke i was watching
with interest as
millions must have been um and the bb
well skye and the bbc did similar
they did a back story on lebanon and
they concentrated one of the things they
said was that the government is corrupt
now
i don't know if they are or they aren't
and then they said that the
currency was devalued by 90 and
they give examples of how terrible life
was in lebanon
and i thought they would have added into
the back story the fact is lebanon was
on the sanctions from the usa
and the eu and they maybe might have
introduced that
there'd been a war there in 2007 with
israel and
not one mention and i just thought that
the news
coverage was was was lacking in uh
in context yeah well they probably had
that
uh package ready uh for the event if you
get my drift the reality is
the devaluation which is actually 800
percent
of the lebanese currencies because of
the sanctions
and the sanctions are being imposed on
lebanon
because of the war in syria
and therefore the regime of sanctions
and the constant attacks
on lebanon virtually daily certainly
weekly are the reason why uh
lebanon is in the state it's in of
course it has
crooks in the government but those
crooks are the best
friends of the western countries
now demanding an end to corruption
in lebanon that's the truth of the
matter
guy last word to you it's it's
it's come to the point now with myself
when i watch the mainstream news
i'm just looking for objective stories i
there's been an explosion the back story
now i just switch off because i know
it will not be a detailed account it
will be a very
edited account well you're only going to
get balance
on rt uh despite the label that they've
slapped on us
i've watched yesterday with mounting
fury
actually as the rt news anchor
in moscow uh interviewed uh
um how shall i put it one of the
anti-government leaders in
in beirut who was reading straight off
the
american french trump macron
script and the interview went on and on
and on
only rt is giving a balanced
view of what's happening in lebanon
even if i didn't like hearing uh that uh
story that franco-american imperialist
story and narrative
endlessly broadcast
on rt uh last evening just goes to show
rt's far more fair and balanced
than the others coming up to the news
let me get a couple of
comments in rita is angry with me i'm
sorry gigi
that nonsense about single parenthood is
rubbish
i'm a mental health clinician and a
single parent
so what you say is absolute nonsense
well you haven't pointed out why
rita but you could call and we'll put
you straight on
roy says thanks for shedding light on
lebanon's situation you are
our voice around the world thank you roy
and rob says a
martial plan for lebanon would be wise
and compassionate
and elias says there is great influence
and misleading children today
especially with drugs and tom says sadly
maxwell will not be going to prison
because
deals have been done to protect the
liberal elites let me take omar
in dubai on lebanon omar welcome to the
show
hi mr george how are you by the grace of
god i'm good thank you what would you
like to say
you know just to say that you're a
legend you're you know you've done a lot
for uh lebanon ever since uh your 2006
interview on sky news that was legendary
thank you
no problem um and i i i actually have a
lebanese friend that recently shared
video with me uh i was wondering what
you think about it it's like seven
months ago in
in syria and a huge explosion with his
same
blast profile you know it doesn't look
like a regular military munitions
it's uh very odd to me where was that i
don't recall that blast omar where was
it
i'm not exactly sure where in syria but
the footage is available on youtube
and it has the exact same sort of low
wide mushroom
cloud really looking explosion and there
was a primary explosion
and um i've seen a lot of videos shared
by my lebanese friends as well
where the people in beirut when the
explosion happened say they they saw it
falling
you know i don't know what they're
referring to but i
i think it it seems compelling that
there was yeah
the lebanese government is uh adamant
that there was no
attack um donald trump was equally
adamant that there had been and he said
his
great generals had told him so uh the
pentagon though
uh de nada afterwards they basically
said they didn't know
what donald trump was talking about i'll
tell you what omar
if you could uh put that a link to that
video
of the syrian explosion up on our
twitter feed that will be helpful
uh then people can uh see what it is
that you are
talking about and thank you very much
indeed for your kind words la shukra
alawajib don't thank me for my duty
and uh one more or two more uh social
media
sadly maxwell i've done that one youtube
says robert
lebanon robert says lebanon also could
turn
into libya and on twitter lisa says i
read somewhere over the weekend
that tulsi gabbard will be biden's vice
president
or was this a hoax i think a hoax lisa
and phil says my two siblings and i were
brought up by my mother
father an alcoholic no interest in his
kids
i have three daughters with my wife and
i am a better father
thanks to the lessons taught to me by my
mum please don't belittle
single parent families
okay what can you say what can you say
maria says i love moats but tonight i'm
here for the baby
thank you maria for that dr fath
says great show george just wondering do
you reckon the american people have a
genuine case
to bring against the democratic party or
establishment
for having a total insult to their
intelligence like
joe biden fostered on them this surely
is a set up and gemma says just heard
your opening about families
that do better when there is a father
around not true
families do best when there are loving
discipline caring encouraging and
protective
parents raising the child whether that
is a mom and dad dad and dad
mom and mom well very right on gemma
uh i have been through the care system
gemma says and the couple who adopted me
at ten
two women are the best parents i could
ever have wished for
and tony says how was epstein a
billionaire
without any business track record at all
indeed indeed indeed
now uh the poll is uh still running
uh will lebanon become the next ukraine
ukraine 17 down to hong kong 14
down one syria 69
up three you can vote now on my twitter
feed
at george galloway it's time i think
for the news with jamie law curious
about our curriculum
have something to say then call us now
to join the debate on the mother of all
talk shows with george galloway
tune in every tuesday to loud and clear
for a regular segment called
false prophets a weekly look at wall
street and corporate capitalism
where we talk about the big economic
issues of the week from the point of
view of working people
the poor and the u.s position in the
global economy join us this tuesday
and every tuesday with financial policy
analyst daniel sankey
right here on radio sputnik
it's time to double down with max and
stacy yeah double down we're talking
markets finance business economics
ka-chang
bling just about everything money
related on sputnik it's called double
down
we're asking are dead cats bouncing or
have fundamentals change
that's this week on double down
radio sputnik we speak your language
find us at sputniknews.com
[Music]
radio sputnik news brazil has hit
a grim milestone of a hundred thousand
coronavirus deaths
only the second country in the world to
do so after the united states
the number of people in the country to
have died with covid19 has rocketed
recently
with the coronavirus taking three months
to kill 50 000 people
and then just 50 days to kill the next
50 000
president jia bolsonaro who caught
coronavirus last month has played down
the gravity of the pandemic and fought
against lockdowns
by local officials the u.s has recorded
425 deaths mexico is behind brazil with
50 2006
and there have been 46 651 in the uk
according to johns hopkins university
protesters in brazil marked the latest
death milestone by projecting
a hundred thousand victims of bolsonaro
onto a building
in rio de janeiro britain's prime
minister boris johnson
says it's a national priority and a
moral duty to get all pupils back in
class next month
raising the prospect of closing shops
pubs and restaurants
in local lockdowns to allow schools to
stay open
in a newspaper article today the prime
minister wrote that social justice
demands
that classrooms are full again and says
education is crucial for children's
welfare and future
especially the most disadvantaged
professor chris whittie the chief
medical officer for england warned last
week that the nation has probably
reached near the limit
or the limits of what can be done to
reopen society safely
and professor neil ferguson whose
modelling led to the decision to impose
the lockdown
suggested ministers would need to roll
back on the relaxation of restrictions
to allow a full-time return to schools
while keeping the virus under control
only 53 percent of britain's would be
certain
or very likely to allow themselves to be
vaccinated against covert 19 according
to new research
one in six said they would definitely
not get a vaccine
or it would be very unlikely in a poll
of around
2 000 people the study found that people
were more likely to reject the vaccine
because of their attitudes and beliefs
about science and authority
rather than reasons related to the
coronavirus itself
young people were twice as likely not to
want a vaccine with 22 percent of 16 to
34 year olds
saying that they would not have one
compared to just 11
of 55 to 75 year olds
us president donald trump has taken
executive action
to provide economic aid to millions of
americans hit by the pandemic
claiming he was forced to do so after
talks at congress broke down
the directives include measures to
support the unemployed
suspend payroll tax and extend student
loans
some of them are likely to face legal
challenges given that congress controls
federal spending not the president
democratic rival joe biden said they
were a series of half-baked measures
negotiations broke down on friday after
two weeks of talks
it's not known whether the move will
mean the end of discussions between
senior government officials and top
democrats for a stimulus package
trump said the measures would provide up
to four hundred dollars in supplemental
unemployment benefits to tens of
millions
of jobless americans this is less than
the six hundred dollars
people have been receiving until the
31st of july
when the benefit expired the uk has
pledged a further 20 million pounds in
aid to lebanon following tuesday's
deadly explosion in beirut
the support will go directly to those
injured and displaced by the explosion
providing access to food and medicine
as well as other urgent supplies the uk
which has already given five million
pounds to the emergency relief effort
said it showed its commitment to stand
by the lebanese people
in that hour of need the blast in this
city's port destroyed large parts of the
surrounding area
killing more than 150 people injuring
more than 5 000
and leaving more than 300 000 homeless
voters are casting their ballots in
belarus with five-term
president alexandra lukashenko facing
his toughest challenge in years
from a political novice although
lukashenko is still expected to win
he faces a prominent rival in 37 year
old
svetlana tikanovskiyer who is running in
place of her jailed husband
lukashenko aged 65 was first elected in
his previous landslide victories were
condemned by political observers
in the last vote in 2015 he was declared
winner with 83.5 percent of the vote
there were no serious challenges and
election observers
reported problems in the counting and
tabulation of votes
today long queues were seen at some
polling stations
including a belarusian embassies abroad
the music mogul simon cowell has broken
his back while testing his new electric
bicycle at his home in california
cowell age 60 was trying out the bike in
the courtyard of his malibu
home when he fell off he is understood
to have had
surgery on saturday evening a political
row between the uk and france over
migrant crossings in the channel has
intensified
with britain's immigration ministers
saying that the unacceptable
increase in numbers simply cannot go on
chris phillip is due to meet his french
counterpart in paris on tuesday
to discuss stronger measures including
interceptions and returns it comes after
151 migrants
reached the uk on saturday taking the
total since the 1st of january to 4100
many arriving in overloaded rubber
dinghies while the southeast england
vast in roasting sunshine today a dozen
more people took advantage of calm seas
to arrive in dover
after making the dangerous crossing
and finally scientists in germany are
trying to create the first northern
white rhino test tube baby
to save the species from extinction the
northern white is functionally extinct
after decades of poaching and the
wholesale loss of natural habitat
there are two remaining females kept
under armed god
at a conservancy in kenya but neither
animal is able to reproduce
the last northern white male named sudan
died in 2018.
inside a concert pen in northern germany
a 17 year old female called karen
has been selected for the critically
important experiment
scientists are trying to turn her into a
mother with fertilized eggs or embryos
created in the lab
theoretically at least in virtua
fertilization or in this case rhino ivf
has the potential to save the northern
white rhino a once numerous grazer which
ranged over large parts of central and
eastern africa
well that's the latest here on sputnik
news i'm jamie lowe
you're listening to radio sputnik
telling the untold
welcome to the open university of the
airwaves
with george callaway only on sputnik
radio
now there'll be a poll on the baby's
name at nine o'clock
and uh exclusive pictures first of our
pictures
of the new baby galloway this current
poll will lebanon
become the next ukraine the next hong
kong or the next syria still running
for the next uh 15 minutes or so and you
can vote
on my twitter feed at george galloway
now i said
all i intend to say about what happened
in beirut rania khalek my colleague the
legendary journalist presenter
and writer and broadcaster was there
when the balloon went up and what a
devastating
explosion it was too uh rania
uh our condolences first and foremost
uh lebanon lost a lot of blood a lot of
people
a lot of damage of all kinds uh
including to its political
infrastructure but let's start with the
human impact first first of all
tell us what it was like
well george first i want to say
congratulations on the new baby i'm very
excited that you had such a great week
and yes it's been a rough week for
lebanon um i was there when the
explosion took place and it's one of the
most terrifying it is the most
terrifying
thing i've ever experienced uh luckily i
came out
uninjured um it was like an earthquake
the windows blew open um
and then you know there's this big loud
sound uh
but i was one of the lucky ones um
almost every single person i know
has an injury uh like over 150 people
have
were found dead and just surveying the
damage in the aftermath you know i
toured
the city after this took place and
walked around and i mean
you know no building no restaurant no
hotel
uh no storefront was left untouched
by this explosion and the pressure that
it created across the city
uh i mean the the level of devastation
was so widespread you know i've been to
syria
i've been to iraq i've seen devastation
from from war
but it's the kind of devastation that
takes you know takes place gradually
one street at a time right one
neighborhood at a time this was an
entire city just you know destruction
as though there had been war there for
years but in a matter of a few minutes
now uh when you look at that devastation
and when you look at the video
uh several angles now
what's your thought about what could
possibly have created
such an explosion such an infernal
well it seems to be the case i mean
people close to hezbollah believe this
lebanese general security
has come to this conclusion and the more
information that comes out the more it
seems that this was a case of
just utter incompetence by a completely
dysfunctional
uh state which lebanon has always been
that left this fertilizer
massive amounts of it sitting in very uh
improper and dangerous conditions for
six years
until a fryer broke out at the port and
it exploded
um you know we knew there was a fire at
the port about
20 25 minutes before
the ammonium nitrate uh caught on fire
so it was a fire that started in a
different part of the port
near the ammonium nitrate and then the
ammonium nitrate caught on fire we know
that over the last six years
there have been several complaints and
warnings about
this material being stored in this way
and so it does seem to have been an
accident of epic proportions
uh that said in the aftermath of this
accident there
are political factions that are allied
with the americans
inside lebanon that are trying to
manipulate the situation
to put the blame on hezbollah which is
completely absurd
um and you know of course the u.s is
encouraging this
i've covered the demonstrations that
started taking place in lebanon next
last year in october
due to the economic collapse there's a
lot of illegitimate anger in the streets
people who are angry at the ruling elite
uh then and now
but there's also rioting taking place
and there's also manipulations by
particular political factions
trying to take advantage of the
situation
to try to push against their political
rivals in this case hezbollah
so that we need to be very clear about
that because the narrative that we see
developing particularly in the western
media
uh is this was hezbollah's fault which
is absolutely untrue this was the fault
of the entire lebanese power structure
of which hezbollah plays one part but
that includes
several political parties the most
corrupt
and uh and at fault of which are
actually the ones that are allied with
the americans
yes i made that point earlier uh
undoubtedly there is
rampant corruption in lebanese
government
there always has been there is in all
arab countries
including the arab countries closest to
the west but the politicians most
corrupt
in lebanon have always been the
politicians
most close to the west 100
you know this economic collapse the
deterioration of lebanon's economy
is the fault of of people like
the hariri family uh which is close to
saudi arabia
and the west uh riyad salemme who's head
of the central bank in lebanon and
actually engineered this entire ponzi
scheme economy
that came crashing down as it ultimately
always would
is basically a puppet of the americans
um
the people that are the most corrupt in
lebanon
are the ones who are always causing the
most problems
and unfortunately we don't get the right
picture of that
in the west because everything that
happens in lebanon
is always portrayed through the lens of
how can we make hezbollah look bad right
because hezbollah
is you know an enemy of israel it's an
ally of iran
america does not like hezbollah they
call them a terrorist group
so everything that happens in lebanon is
always viewed in that lens in the west
and it's just
wrong um lebanon is a very polarized
place
but the lebanese that end up getting
attention in the western press
end up being people who are allied with
these pro-american parties and
the situation is much more complicated
and complex and nuanced than that
well uh in my uh in my monologue at the
beginning i was
making some i hope salient points
um if we had proper democracy
in lebanon then of course hezbollah
would have an overwhelming majority
in the lebanese parliament and hassan
nasrallah would be the president
it's possible yeah and it's only
because hezbollah doesn't want
to take power in lebanon because it
wants to keep
the sectarian fragile sectarian balance
so that the christians can always have
the president
so that the sunnis can always have the
premiership
so this is a bit of a handicap to
western propagandists isn't it because
they can't demand democracy in lebanon
because democracy would give them the
result they least want
exactly and even in this system that we
have hezbollah does win
a large amount of seats in parliament
because hezbollah has a huge
constituency
and they have a huge constituency
because they are well respected
in their community because they're seen
as protectors they're seen as protectors
against the israelis who occupied
southern lebanon
in a brew like a brutal occupation just
like they do to palestine
for dec for years uh and the only reason
that israel no longer occupies southern
lebanon is because hezbollah kicked them
out
um with force uh hezbollah also played a
very significant role
with uh the arming and funding of
jihadist groups in syria
they those groups tried to make their
way into lebanon including isis
as well as the uh litany of
american-backed
uh you know rev so-called you know
revolutionary rebel groups that actually
were
jihadist groups allied with al-qaeda
these groups tried to make their way
into lebanon
and the only reason they didn't make it
to beirut is because of hezbollah
that's the only reason i mean
hezbollah's existence is to
protect the borders and the sovereignty
of lebanon that's how they perceive
themselves
and their community perceives them that
way so that's why they have popularity
within particularly the shia community
in lebanon um but of course there's a
lot of propaganda in lebanon
there's other political factions that
view everything through sectarian lens
and despise hezbollah because those are
their political rivals who are allied
with the saudis who are allied with the
americans
and so it's it's really important that
people understand that when you do read
news about lebanon
uh you need to take everything with a
grain of salt because it's cut
it's being filtered through a western
press that has a very
uh a very um nefarious agenda
about what they want to happen there now
we've we've both seen many times the
protests and demonstrations and so on
around the governmental buildings the
parliament building
in downtown beirut but yesterday's
seemed of
a more serious order they were able to
break into several ministries uh
can the current government of lebanon
survive and if it were to fall
what would be the uh the successor
government so i do want to do a break so
i do want to be clear about the protest
that took place yesterday there was of
course that those protests were
multifaceted there was people who were
angry because they lost their homes
because of the explosion because of the
corruption
and of course there was also rioters who
were sent in there with an agenda that
belonged to certain political factions
and there was also people who were poor
and were using it as an opportunity to
you know loot what they could because
they got they have nothing
um so that's important to to recognize
but as for the government i mean this
government
is was always a temporary government
that was very weak
that came about last year after the
government of saad hadidi basically
resigned
in the aftermath of the october 17th
protest
um and so you know this government is
now under extreme pressure because of
the explosions but not just the
explosion the explosion came on top of
this economic crisis that was causing a
almost
overnight deterioration in living
standards in lebanon
uh lebanon went from being a pretty
middle-class uh well-off
decent country for a lot of people to
having power cuts that last 20 hours a
day
uh to having an unemployment rate that's
you know skyrocketing
expected to reach 50 by the end of the
year
uh not just because of covet-19 though
that's a part of it but also because
of the economic collapse um
so this government resigning was sort of
always inevitable it was just a matter
of time of when they would end up
resigning and the explosion
was just so severe and catastrophic it's
caused that now
they're resilient they have these mass
resignations and calls for
new elect do parliamentary elections but
the thing is lebanon like you mentioned
earlier
it's it has a governmental system that's
set up based on sect it allocates power
based on sect and because of that
lebanon
is always going to have people who are
voting for their sect leaders
and so the same people the same uh the
same
power structures continue to be elected
in lebanon because of the way the system
is set up
as long as it's set up bisect you're
gonna continue to have the same people
maybe maybe different names and
different faces but the same
ultimately the same elites being in
charge of the country
so as long as that stays the same
lebanon's going to stay the same lebanon
is going to continue to be a place where
you know legalized theft and bribery and
corruption
uh destroys everything and until that
changes you're not going to see a real
change no matter what government takes
power
lastly and i'm grateful for your time
rania um
the infantilism
uh on display from some quarters
uh in lebanon when president macron
arrived the
cry that france is our mother and
even some asking for uh a renewal of the
french mandate
uh over lebanon how far does that go
surely not far so i think it's i just
want to note that
it's it's interesting to me that macron
cannot walk around parts of france
without being booed
uh but he can come to places like
lebanon and be cheered right
yeah um in the aftermath of a desperate
explosion but
also you know the areas of beirut that
were impacted the hardest because of
their proximity to the port
are areas that are christian areas um
that are
the constituency in those areas is
allied with parties like the lebanese
forces and like the conseil party which
are right-wing christian parties that
are allied with the u.s
and are essentially like pro-israel
parties um
and so the people in these areas speak
french they have a very
um not all of them but there is a
colonial legacy and mentality because
lebanon was initially supposed to
thought of when they carved up the
middle east as being france's little
like christian
you know island and a sea of muslims if
you will
and so there are people who view
themselves as christians in lebanon
as sort of like french culturally they
even speak french
they go to french schools so the area
macron was touring
is an area where france and the french
are viewed
in a very in the colonial legacy of
france is viewed in a very positive
light
it certainly does not reflect the views
across lebanon at all
rania thanks for joining us and thank
god
you survived the horror of this week
in beirut thank you again for joining us
you can vote now uh on our poll will
lebanon be the next
ukraine hong kong or syria
syria is up to 70 now certainly that's
the
hope of those who wish to pull the rug
from
underneath the state of lebanon 636 of
you
have voted there'll be a new poll at
nine o'clock
where i'll be asking you to help me
pick the name of my latest child now you
can call now
you'll get through there's a couple of
free lines uh in the
building here's the numbers again oh two
oh seven
seven nine eight two two five five if
you're calling in the uk
or from the us zero zero one seven
five seven seven four four four four
eight zero sixty second break there you
[Music]
go
tune in every thursday to loud and clear
with brian becker for a regular segment
called criminal injustice about the most
egregious conduct of our courts
and how justice is denied to so many
people in this country
tune in to loud and clear this thursday
and every thursday for thorough and
independent analysis of our criminal
injustice system
[Music]
the giant labour party sailing clearance
is now on
hurry now as we've got zero interest in
our party
it's literally the lowest it's ever been
give up on the common man and save today
that's right we're getting rid of all of
the corbynites
literally every single one being a
blairite has
never been more in style only available
at what should be the uk's biggest
political party
the new new labour party we're doing
this again
we are above all the latest developments
and we don't
take any sides radio sputnik
telling the untold
george galloway and the mother of all
talk shows
join us at the college of knowledge
where there are no tuition fees
now there are many peculiarities about
politics today
is the left right is the right left uh
what do these terms mean
anymore and we have a conservative
government that sometimes seems
to be throwing public money around like
a drunken sailor
at least in some directions usually to
the
corporations and the people with whom
they're closest
but the eat out to help out scheme
is a particularly controversial one
from my point of view because the same
government that is
that is sending messages that
the obesity crisis in britain which is a
real one
is a clear and present danger in the
time
of the coronavirus is giving you
50 percent of your mcdonald's
or your nandos or whatever your junk
food of choice
is i'm not making that up for
foreign viewers and listeners if you go
on a certain day of the week and if you
can get in
to a junk food outlet
you get 50 off your bill and the
government
makes up the other 50 to the
purveyor now not everyone's against it
neil davey
is a prominent journalist and author uh
on these
kind of issues particularly on the
restaurant industry and hospitality in
general
and i'm glad to see that neil joins us
now neil welcome what about my obesity
point
good evening george um it's you have a
very very
valid point on that score it is
um like so many things during this um
the last however many years of this
particular government there are many
things that appear to be contradictory
from an industry perspective
um i think it's a very good
thing the uh the hospitality industry
has not been supported particularly well
through the the furlough scheme um
and if you're trying to restore
confidence using a sector that
by its very nature has high hygiene and
cleanliness standards
is probably a good way of getting a
little bit of confidence back
from the the average punter and how is
it working
neil uh i mean i i haven't myself
availed myself
of it i because partly because i don't
actually approve of it as a use of
public money
uh but my colleagues through the glass
here they've been trying to find a place
that they could get in
to get their uh their uh their discount
which seemed to suggest it's being
widely taken up
it it is um it runs it's monday to
wednesday
um until the 31st of august
it's 50 off your bill to a maximum of 10
pounds
um it's i know
it's very and it doesn't include
alcoholic drinks does include
um soft drinks so i mean it's not
necessarily a case i mean i've been to a
couple of cafes not even realizing they
were part of the scheme
and last week and paid one pound 20 for
a coffee
so there's a lot of places that are
participating without necessarily
um sort of pushing it out as a publicity
thing
a lot of the restaurants that are doing
incredibly well
through this they've picked up an awful
lot of bookings whether it maintains
after the 31st of august
is the kind of the big question how is
the sector
fared neil i mean obviously a lot of
people
uh depend on it for their livelihood
and of course if i missed anything
in the lockdown i missed going to
restaurants
so i'm not trying to be saint francis
here
absolutely how badly has the sector been
hit
it's it's been quite devastating i mean
from there for the sector for the
support industries
um i mean it's a huge huge part of
british social life it's a huge huge
part of the economy
um and the most recent figures i could
find suggest it's
it's worth around 100 billion pounds a
year to the uk economy
um and that's and that's not necessarily
including
the the producers the suppliers the
makers of
cleaning equipment all the other sort of
peripheral things that sort of go into
the industry
um a lot of the staff um
when if they were furloughed the one of
the
negative things that the government had
done they didn't include something
called the trunk
system um which is a
system by which so a lot of as you can
imagine a lot of hospitality staff
receive massive top-ups to their income
through service charges and tips
um the trunk system means that is
reported to the government it is taxable
because they pay income tax on this
level um
when they furloughed stuff they did it
on the non-trunk
rate so a lot of people instead of being
on 80
of their salary were probably on
somewhere between 40 and 60 percent of
their salary yeah
for for several months which has been a
huge struggle
um i mean across the industry across
supplies
you've seen a lot of companies and a lot
of restaurants have pivoted they've
started doing
deliveries they started doing meal kits
they've started doing
delivery of fresh produce and
ingredients just to kind of keep teams
together
just to keep some income coming in um
this has been a massive boost to the
sector as far as i can see
the concern is what happens if it's
going to be the first sector that gets
closed again
and what happens on the 1st of september
when they stop yeah well i mean these
lockdowns
have closed i mean in aberdeen you can't
go now to a pub or a
restaurant and presumably the same is
true in the affected parts of greater
manchester
um so there is always the possibility of
another
uh short sharp or even longer
uh lockdown now on the face of it
you'd imagine that the bigger the chain
restaurant uh the more likely it is to
survive but i notice uh that pizza
express
next door uh to us here
has not reopened and will not reopen
uh perhaps hundreds of its outlets
so even big and well-known chains
might not survive this absolutely it's
it's
been very very tough times the i mean
before all of this kicked off or before
everything sort of covered 19 related
happened
you had massive increases in in rent you
had massive increases in
business rates so a lot of companies
um have been referred to as zombie
companies they were kind of the walking
dead before this
to some extent i think pizza express
might be a victim of that
um and believe they're closing 67 sites
i think they've been struggling for a
little while it is going to give a few
businesses an opportunity
to perhaps sort of fold
go out of business close an awful lot of
outlets
and with a suitable scapegoat
where perhaps it's not been uh they've
not been successful for a long long time
um perhaps been
for whatever reason um it's gonna be
quite how a lot of these things will
bounce back i don't know the
there's not a great rush for new places
to come in
certainly in the center of towns the i
think neighborhood places are going to
thrive
before the center of town i mean soho
for example i know so many people
working in and around soho who aren't
renewing leases who aren't going back
into the center of town they will be
based
uh neil i mean i now only go to a place
where i can sit outside for example
exactly i haven't yet been inside a
restaurant
and i'm not sure that i i ever will
again
how much do you think this will change
things if you like
fundamentally i see a lot of people
now talking about cooking that they are
doing at home
including people who never cooked before
do you think takeaways home cooking
is going to continue to grow uh
and maybe we'll never get back to
absolutely
completely agree i i don't know what the
um the landscape is going to look like i
mean
at the start of all of this there were
an awful lot of webinars for the
industry
i sort of sat through a few things on
zoom and it always seemed to be
take an hour and a half to come to the
conclusion of well we don't know what
it's going to look like but we've got to
be ready for it when it happens
i think well that's yeah thanks thanks
that was uh yeah great
great wisdom and really worth four and a
half hours of my life so
no one really knows what it's going to
look like i think
things as you say eating at home
is still going to be a big part of that
i think a lot of restaurants are now
taking advantage of that
there are an awful lot of restaurants
doing mail out kits there are great
restaurants that are selling their
ingredients
um places like hawksbill goodman are
sending out steak boxes
of quite fantastic meat to their
customers and
and to others there's there's a lot of
um people who've pivoted very very
effectively
to get their things out to a wider
audience and in some cases
going from just regional to nationwide
the
uh it's going to be i think for an awful
lot of restaurants it's also a revenue
stream they've maybe not considered in
the past
so i think that could be a vital part
certainly again on the neighborhood
thing would be interesting to see what
happens i mean soho and common garden
have pedestrianized a
number of streets so they put outdoor
seating
like you i would much prefer to be
sitting outside
uh quite how that will feel in
october uh remains to be good remains to
be seen
neil i've enjoyed talking to you really
uh i'm really interested
in the subject thanks for joining us on
the mother of
all talk shows now we'll be talking
about children
needing fathers seems to be rather a
more controversial
idea than i'd thought but first
60 second break why don't we
radio sputnik
[Music]
tune in every wednesday to loud and
clear with brian becker and john
kiriakou for a regular segment called
beyond nuclear where brian and john
discuss nuclear issues
including weapons energy waste and the
future of nuclear technology in the
united states
with kevin camps the radioactive waste
watchdog at the organization beyond
nuclear listen on wednesdays right here
on radio slipping
[Music]
want to talk get in touch with us at
radio at sputniknews.com
we are talking 24 hours a day seven days
a week
you are listening
we give you the most essential out of
the endless information space
radio sputnik telling the untold
radio sputnik we speak your language
find us at sputniknews.com
[Music]
hello america it is me joe
biden i think i'm not
[Music]
capable of speaking for myself
myself
[Music]
radio sputnik
george galloway and the mother of all
talk shows join us at the college of
knowledge
where there are no tuition fees
that joe biden's sounding brighter than
i thought
he would now poll number one will
lebanon become the next ukraine
the next hong kong or the next syria
you're running out of time
to get your point of view uh expressed
you can vote
on my twitter feed now uh
michael lykovic is director of
communication
families need fathers and he should be
joining me now michael i hope i got your
name
uh right please forgive me if i didn't
uh that's pretty good thank you george i
appreciate it
now look i'm a father and i believe in
fatherhood
i believe fathers have responsibilities
and i believe and i expressed it so
that children need fathers and a mother
and father are the best model that
society has come up with so far for
bringing up children that turns out to
be
a quite controversial set of views i've
got
according to the paperwork uh i'm uh
receiving so help me out here
well i mean your views shouldn't be
controversial in many countries they're
not controversial
um over here actually in terms of the
public for the public they're not
particularly controversial
um 75 80 percent of it all
people's parents think that both parents
after separation should continue to have
full involvement with their children
um unfortunately that's not the reality
then of what actually happens
in the sort of family justice and
support system that we have over here in
the uk
um which creates massive problems and
and
we have a system of support that's not
fit for purpose
and the result is that you have a lot of
people who think that
it doesn't work and it breaks down which
is true it does
it breaks down it doesn't work
effectively um people
there aren't effective out of court
routes for people to come to agreements
there is no coherent government strategy
for separated families
the result is that it pits parents
against each other
and we end up with the worst of all
worlds and in particular the children
suffer
their well-being suffers and and the
adults too so
we we have a frightful situation but
your
your beliefs are actually very
reasonable
and there's nothing wrong with those um
the leaders in the world are countries
like for example sweden finland
uh many of the scandinavian countries
but they're not the only ones
um actually have a strategy and a
national strategy which they've been
applying for the last 40 50 years
which is to promote and encourage the
involvement of fathers as well as
mothers in the care as well as the
provision financially
of support for children and and they've
been very effective with that strategy
they've been building on it
the well-being of children is much
stronger they have many fewer
mental health issues um there's
something like a 30 percent
differential between in
well-being of children who have both
parents fully involved in their
upbringing
after separation versus those who do not
so
the evidence is there we just don't have
the commitment
to make the change to make the necessary
changes that will make a difference
and actually help parents to separate in
ways that
support their children and and actually
is ultimately best for everybody
now uh let's start with uh because
fathers
have got rights children have got rights
but fathers have
responsibilities also uh and there's a
major problem isn't that
uh in this country in the united states
i'd hazard a guest
or father's not shouldering their
responsibilities
how big uh problem is that
well it depends which responsibility
you're talking about are you talking
primarily about financial responsibility
or caring responsibilities
but you are right i mean the us and the
uk
are amongst the worst in terms of the
provision
they offer for example for paternity
leave for parental leave for dads
when children are born so um it's not
entirely surprising that they're
they are that bit less inclined to
provide care time for their children
because they are so so terribly
undersupported
we have some of the in in time terms we
have some of the most generous
maternity provisions in the world out of
oecd countries
and we're down there right at the bottom
along with the united states of the
rankings
on paternity leave i mean the us is not
very good on maternity leave or
paternity leave
but but we are particularly bad on that
provision
and if you go for example somewhere like
sweden or finland you'll find that
dads are given three months of
paternity leave at funded at sort of
around
80 percent of their salaries um
as well as mums and this has been a
deliberate strategy to engage them from
a very early age so that dads actually
get to
spend care time with their children
and for example in finland um
two or three years ago finland became
the first country in the world where
dads actually spend longer caring for
their children
than mums do we're only talking about a
very small difference you know eight
minutes a day
so in effect they've achieved equality
but they have achieved it through
policy government policy of supporting
dads
in supporting their children not only
financially
but also in terms of um care time
and and they're paying the dividends
they're really reaping the bit of the
dividends of that in the well-being of
their children but also in other areas
so for example
um the the gender pay gap is narrowest
in those countries which offer the best
um and most generous that is an
interesting point but nonetheless
uh michael we both know no point in
hiding from it
there's a significant number of fathers
who that just do a runner
uh they don't pay unless the
government can catch up with them and
even then it's like
drawing teeth and a lot of fathers
simply
don't want to be involved they've moved
on and their
dislike of the mother
means that they no longer care for their
children
and and this is a serious problem but
the problem is also not being very
effectively stated in in the what we
hear mostly in the media
yes there is a problem with so-called
deadbeat dads those who kind of run away
and don't support them and
we would argue of course had they been
more involved with their children they
would be more supportive and we know
from the figures that
involved fathers are much better at
financially supporting
uh their children and the mums of their
children as well so there's an issue
around
involvement and how the system supports
their involvement but but also
there's a lot of misrepresentation of
what actually is going on in terms of
the financial support and not not
committing to the children there's a
huge amount of debt which is accrued and
the old csa and now under cms child
maintenance service
of of child support arrears but actually
when you look at those areas you'll find
that the vast
vast majority of it is are arrears from
people on extremely low
incomes so you're actually in many cases
dealing with a problem of poverty
more than you are of abandonment of
responsibility
um you know a lot of if you you know we
there's a lot of the work that's been
done included by both
agencies of the government and even the
centers for social justice that
developed
universal credit has identified that
there's a problem in the way that
the child maintenance calculation works
and the problem is particularly
horrendous
for people on low incomes on minimum
wages or
who are kind of a part-time work who or
in in
in gig economy work the the
the formula just breaks down because it
actually means that they
by the time they have paid their child
maintenance they cannot afford to pay
for a roof over their own head
um to to live and to to pay for their
own food in their own day-to-day
essential living costs so
i mean we did a survey a few years ago
and 17
of dads who responded to that particular
server i appreciate it's not a
scientific survey
um said that they gave up work
completely because it didn't pay for
them
now you know dwp know this the
department of work and pensions know
this the government know this
it's been reported in many many
authoritative sources to them
but they continue to drag their feet in
trying to do something about it it's one
of those
hot potato issues that they they don't
really want to address
now turning to the father's rights
let's be blunt it is perfectly possible
in fact it is it is
uh remarkably common
uh that uh where uh wife
a mother uh decides are we still got
michael there
yeah i'm here yeah the mother uh decides
that she
no longer wants the father
and immediately the
father's relationship with the children
is oftentimes fantastically dramatically
disrupted so one minute you're living
with your children
uh you might be a very good father
but their mother no longer likes you
tells you to leave
and then you're on once a fortnight
for for a few hours
and only after transient
negotiation this is very painful
uh for a father but it's also
potentially disastrous for the children
isn't it
it's absolutely frightful we we don't
have
a uh presumption of shared care in law a
rebuttable presumption
which means that in effect what happens
is that possession of the children
becomes ninety percent of the law
and it's very easy for um
what is usually mothers it can be
fathers too but it's usually mothers in
these situations
who if they don't wish the father to
have contact to simply stop it
and and other and then the only recourse
you have i mean you can try mediation
but somebody who's determined to block
you out of that relationship
will block you out they will simply stop
it and your then
only recourse is to try to turn to the
support of um
family justice and family justice is
frightfully ineffective and actually
adds to the harm because it's that we
have an adversarial
justice system um and and we have in
this view in this country one of the
worst problems in the world certainly in
the
developed world we have one of the worst
problems we have 65 000 children
involved every year in private law cases
that's around 10 of births every year
36 of families are separating before
their children he reached the age of
16 um and they go and they rely on the
family courts
to assist them but actually the family
courts are not fit for purpose
it typically takes the official figures
say that it takes 29
weeks to get to a final arrangement from
a court
now those figures we know are
understated because they
because of repeat cases that come back
so in reality it's probably about three
quarters of a year on
average and now under kovid we can
expect that to go up to be over a year
so it is a frightful frightful situation
and by that
and a year or six months or a year is an
absolute age for a six-year-old or a
five-year-old
it's it's it's an eternity and the
damage that's being done is absolutely
colossal
both to the father usually occasionally
mum
and absolutely to the children who get
caught up in it in the in the
adversarial
fight and the battle that ensues so what
we have
really is a public health issue an
urgent public health issue
that demands proper coordinated
government attention
to have a proper strategy an effective
strategy for how
separated parents should be assisted
we have no guidance for example in what
the care arrangement should be
so parents go to court not no not
knowing what to expect
they might have avoided going to court
if they knew that
without domestic abuse or other
extenuating circumstances
that they might get a certain share of
care time
but there is no published guidance it's
a it's it's a sort of a no man's land
yeah well it's hit and miss depending on
who the
judge is and of course there's now no
legal aid
for people in though in the family
justice system and it's sits in secret
uh for obvious reasons but that means
it's not subject to political or
public scrutiny in the way that other
parts
of the justice system are and uh
i mean it goes without saying that you
could be the father
one day madly in love with your children
uh kicked out of the relationship
and a boyfriend can move in the next day
uh without any checks at all
on their suitability and they're
suddenly with your children
24 hours a day and you're lucky if you
see them once a week
you're absolutely right george i mean
this is absolutely horrendous
that you know we we want there to be um
a rebuttable presumption that both
parents will be involved
we also would like to see something akin
to what they do in florida which is they
have a standing temporary order
which means as soon as people separate
they have a
an order which basically stipulates a
certain
minimum amount of time that the child is
going to spend with each parent
and if anybody wants to contest that
they can have an urgent hearing to
make representations why that shouldn't
be the case but over here we
force people through the most awful
painful process as you say to sometimes
just get an hour a week or two or
nothing
and and as time goes by the delays in
the system are so terrible
that as time goes by the the the status
quo becomes the norm
and the status quo ends up being with
the children being
with their mums in most cases and dads
actually good dads we're not talking
about
people who are harmful to their children
we're talking about good dads who want
to care and be responsible for their
children
who want to provide care time who want
to support them financially
who find themselves denied reasonable
arrangements
and we know that children benefit so
much from having both of their parents
they're part of their identity they are
who they are and and you're quite right
george
the issue with legal aid i mean the
government removed it
um 2012 act so but from 2013 onwards
there's essentially no legal aid um
unless there's allegations of domestic
abuse which are made
um and then only to one party so
so the effect is that as as for james
mundy the previous president of the
family division said
um private family law has become a
lawyer-free zone
and what you've got is very vulnerable
people who have no income who call
income who cannot afford the 250 or more
pounds
an hour that a lawyer will cost them um
who i get before a judge having never
been in court before
trying to explain why having to defend
why they need to
need to be or should be involved in
their children's lives
just because somebody has said no i'm
not letting you because they're angry
because they're bitter because they've
moved on and found a new partner
it's absolutely horrendous and totally
unacceptable and
we need to have a complete reinvention
of the system
with better education better out of
court settlement routes
clear guidance about shared care
arrangements after separation and the
benefits to children
and and ways of keeping people out of
this divisive
system which is it does such
colossal damage to children and and and
their parents
it's beyond imagination and then by the
way you know if you have gone to court
and those who have
paid for lawyers in our own survey each
either spent 20 on average 23 000 pounds
a huge amount of money from those people
and you've got your precious court order
which says you're going to see your
child every other week
and there's no certainty that it will be
complied with or obeyed
it's often it's often simply uh
not implemented and then what do you do
spend thousands more
wait many more months exactly i wish we
had more time michael
alas we don't it's been a pleasure uh
talking to you even
about such a distressing subject thank
you very much indeed
michael levcovich of the
families need fathers movements let me
know
what you think of what you have heard
there
but let me take a call from beirut
anastasia
is on the line anastasia welcome
hi george thank you uh congratulations
on the newborn
thank you and thank you for this
platform as well
um i just wanted to to share with you a
bit uh
what i think about uh what's going on in
lebanon
i am lebanese myself um i definitely
don't think that lebanon will be the
next syria or ukraine
of course the situation started
destabilizing when
um hezbollah and its allies were elected
by the people
to run the government um it will
definitely not be easy it is a war that
we're facing right now
um but we will not be syria i mean
hopefully
we will not be syria or ukraine or hong
kong
um and about the blacks hong kong
yesterday anastasia
sorry it looked a bit like hong kong
yesterday
yeah it did but uh definitely uh because
of the blast
because of everything uh going on
detention
um the feelings the emotion that the
people
are currently uh experimenting uh of
course the situation does not seem very
stable but knowing the lebanese
community and the lebanese behavior and
um um the the fatigue that we have or
that we
um um we feel or like um
will not allow us to continue with these
um uh i don't know these uh behaviors i
would say
um the blast definitely was
was not a coincidence or pure accidents
i mean everybody is saying that yes um
the nonchalance of the government and
and
led to this explosion but i mean the
timeline
seems a little bit weird and a bit too
convenient um for the anti-government
um parties and and and the west and if
you look generally at the at the
catastrophes or like the man-made castro
around the world
um they usually come either after war
before war or like during war it is just
like
um this all seems very weird and and
talking about uh from a um business
aspect you know um somebody just
deciding that they want to leave the
uh ammonium nitrate um because they're
just like tired of the litigation and
it just seems like absurd and it doesn't
make any sense that somebody would just
like um
leave their um
the the material was worth millions of
dollars
exactly so so why would somebody just
like
leave it out there and just not claim it
back so this
is this is nonsense and this doesn't
make any sense and and
and looking at it from uh from from
everything going on around
in the middle east and and and um
the the the power dynamics changing it
just does not seem a coincidence and
like using
the protesters and i would say no the
the the political parties using
this um at this tragic
uh event for their
uh for their um i would say for their
uh interest or like uh political gain i
mean
uh yeah it all sounds very strange very
bizarre very absurd
anastasia thank you for that call from
the front line
in uh beirut oh two oh seven seven nine
eight two two five five if you're in the
uk if you're in the u.s
zero zero one seven five seven seven
four
four four four eight zero i'll be back
right after the news curious about our
curriculum
have something to say then call us now
to join the debate
on the mother of all talk shows with
george galloway
tune in every tuesday to loud and clear
for a regular segment called
false prophets a weekly look at wall
street and corporate capitalism
where we talk about the big economic
issues of the week from the point of
view of working people
the poor and the us position in the
global economy join us this tuesday and
every tuesday with financial policy
analyst daniel sankey
right here on radio sputnik
[Music]
it's time to double down with max and
stacy yeah double down we're talking
markets finance business economics
bling just about everything money
related on sputnik it's called double
down
we're asking are dead cats bouncing or
have fundamentals change
that's this week on double down
[Music]
radio sputnik we speak your language
find us at sputniknews.com
[Music]
radio sputnik news brazil has hit a grim
milestone
of a hundred thousand coronavirus deaths
only the second country in the world to
do so
after the united states the number of
people in the country to have died with
covid 19 has rocketed recently
with the coronavirus taking three months
to kill 50 000 people and then just 50
days to kill the next fifty thousand
president jia bolsonaro who caught
coronavirus last month has played down
the gravity of the pandemic and fought
against lockdowns
by local officials the us has recorded
425 deaths mexico is behind brazil with
52 0006
and there have been 46 651
in the uk according to johns hopkins
university
protesters in brazil marked the latest
death milestone by projecting a hundred
thousand victims of bolsonaro
onto a building in rio de janeiro
britain's prime minister boris johnson
says it's a national priority and a
moral duty to get all pupils back
in class next month raising the prospect
of closing shops pubs and restaurants
in local lockdowns to allow schools to
stay open
in a newspaper article today the prime
minister wrote that social justice
demands
that classrooms are full again and says
education is crucial for children's
welfare and future
especially the most disadvantaged
professor chris whittie the chief
medical officer for england warned last
week that the nation has probably
reached near the limit
or the limits of what can be done to
reopen society safely
and professor neil ferguson whose
modeling led to the decision to impose
the lockdown
suggested ministers would need to roll
back on the relaxation of restrictions
to allow a full-time return to schools
while keeping the virus under control
only 53 percent of britain's would be
certain or very likely
to allow themselves to be vaccinated
against covert 19 according to new
research
one in six said they would definitely
not get a vaccine
or it would be very unlikely in a poll
of around 2
000 people the study found that people
were more likely to reject the vaccine
because of their attitudes and beliefs
about science and authority
rather than reasons related to the
coronavirus itself
young people were twice as likely not to
want a vaccine with 22
of 16 to 34 year olds saying that they
would not have one compared to just 11
percent
of 55 to 75 year olds
us president donald trump has taken
executive action
to provide economic aid to millions of
americans hit by the pandemic
claiming he was forced to do so after
talks at congress broke down
the directives include measures to
support the unemployed
suspend payroll tax and extend student
loans
some of them are likely to face legal
challenges given that congress controls
federal spending not the president
democratic rival joe biden
said they were a series of half-baked
measures negotiations broke down
on friday after two weeks of talks it's
not known whether the move will mean the
end of discussions between senior
government officials and top democrats
for a stimulus package trump said the
measures would provide
up to four hundred dollars in
supplemental unemployment benefits to
tens of millions
of jobless americans this is less than
the 600
people had been receiving until the 31st
of july
when the benefit expired the uk has
pledged a further 20 million pounds in
aid to lebanon following tuesday's
deadly explosion in beirut
the support will go directly to those
injured and displaced by the explosion
providing access to food and medicine
as well as other urgent supplies the uk
which has already given five million
pounds to the emergency relief effort
said it showed its commitment to stand
by the lebanese people in that hour of
need
the blast in this city's port destroyed
large parts of the surrounding area
killing more than 150 people injuring
more than 5000
and leaving more than 300 000 homeless
voters are casting their ballots in
belarus with five-term
president alexandre lukashenko facing
his toughest challenge in years
from a political novice although
lukashenko is still expected to win
he faces a prominent rival in 37 year
old svetlana tikkanovskiya
who is running in place of her jailed
husband lukashenko aged 65 was first
elected in 1994
his previous landslide victories were
condemned by political observers
in the last vote in 2015 he was declared
winner with 83.5 percent of the vote
there were no serious challenges and
election observers
reported problems in the counting and
tabulation of votes
today long queues were seen at some
polling stations
including belarusian embassies abroad
the music mogul simon cowell has broken
his back while testing his new electric
bicycle at his home in california
cowell aged 60 was trying out the bike
in the courtyard of his malibu home
when he fell off he is understood to
have had surgery on saturday evening
a political row between the uk and
france over migrant crossings in the
channel has intensified
with britain's immigration minister
saying that the unacceptable increase in
numbers simply
cannot go on chris phillip is due to
meet his french counterpart in paris on
tuesday
to discuss stronger measures including
interceptions and returns
it comes after migrants reached the uk
on saturday taking the total since the
1st of january to 4100 many arriving in
overloaded rubber dinghies
while the southeast england vast in
roasting sunshine today a dozen more
people took advantage
of calm seas to arrive in dover after
making the dangerous crossing
and finally scientists in germany are
trying to create the first northern
white rhino test tube baby
to save the species from extinction the
northern white is
functionally extinct after decades of
poaching and the wholesale loss of
natural habitat
there are two remaining females kept
under armed god
at a conservancy in kenya but neither
animal is able to reproduce
the last northern white male named sudan
died in 2018.
inside a concert pen in northern germany
a 17 year old female called karen
has been selected for the critically
important experiment
scientists are trying to turn her into a
mother with fertilized eggs or
embryos created in the lab theoretically
at least
in virtual fertilization or in this case
rhino ivf
has the potential to save the northern
white rhino a once numerous grazer which
ranged over large parts of central and
eastern africa
well that's the latest here on sputnik
news i'm jamie lowe
you're listening to radio sputnik
telling the untold
welcome to the open university of the
airwaves
with george galloway only on sputnik
radio
now my friends thought i might need some
help in picking a name for
my new child so they've come up with
a nicola b maggie
and i don't even know how to say the
third one persephone
persephone c persephone
persephone i have no idea which century
that comes from so a nicola b
maggie c persephone or you can leave a
comment
on my twitter feed suggesting your own
name and many
have been kind enough to do so uh
already later
before the end of the show i'll show you
our picture and
tell you if i've accepted any of your
suggested names
um now you remember omar in
dubai referred to a video showing
an explosion in syria which was
remarkably
similar to the one that took place in
beirut and so we went looking for it
and the lads have found it can we
can we see it
it is another amazing mushroom type
affair i can't see the colour of it is
the smoke red
like the smoke in beirut was red
that i can't see but it is uh
it is extraordinary it's not
read and this was seven months ago
well it's one of these uh coincidences
perhaps and now dr ranjit
who has helped us through every day
of the crisis which shows no signs
of ending the coronavirus crisis
is spiraling in some places particularly
in the united states
out of control literally
out of control and nothing that the
president says or does from the
podium from the presidency uh
helps apparently in any way
here in britain where we have
one of the worst outcomes in the whole
world
that's england and scotland despite
propaganda
to the contrary uh scotland has the
third worst outcome in the world
uh britain as a whole has the
contrary to
propaganda there is no material
difference
between the outcomes in england and in
scotland both
are dreadful and now we have uh
new lockdowns in scotland in aberdeen
which is causing a lot of controversy
and in northwest england in the greater
manchester
area now extended to preston
so we better hear from the doctor just
how he thinks
this is all developing dr ranjit thanks
as always
for joining us tell us if you will
the thinking behind new lockdowns
and whether they are likely to become a
new normal i.e
local regional lockdowns rather than
one size fits all
george thanks for having me back on
pleasure to be with you and
congratulations on the birth of your
thank you baby daughter
thank you i think stephanie's a nice
name by the way okay
sorry sticking to topic um you know the
as you say coronavirus
very much still with us uh almost 20
million
cases test diagnosed in the world with
732 000 deaths
and the united states this week exceeded
uh 5 million
brazil exceeded 3 million and india
2.2 million so cases absolutely out of
control in a whole swathe of states
across the southern and eastern
part of the united states in particular
from texas all the way through tennessee
georgia
florida up to towards new york where
there are fewer cases now but many many
many states
experiencing a surge an increase in uh
cases and an increase of deaths and
they're
having the problem of um really greater
than a thousand deaths again
per day for the last three weeks and a
few days less but on average greater
than a thousand deaths a day for the
last three weeks
um in the united kingdom clearly our
death rate has fallen
markedly compared to the peak where we
also had a three week period
of a thousand deaths per day of course
we're a very much
smaller country than the united states
so that's really as as you say very much
more significant in terms of
cases per million of the population um
which is why we have the the poor
outcome
relatively speaking you're you're
talking about
the trouble with our uh approach the
coronavirus has always been the same and
i i don't like to be repetitive i would
love to give good news and say that
we're doing a wonderful job
but i fear that we're not doing a
wonderful job and the public health
measures
remain the only really effective
measures we have against kovid
those nations which have basically
returned to normal are those which have
effectively eliminated
copper george and it can be done and it
should be done and that was the correct
approach clearly it's easier to
eliminate when the numbers are small
than when they're large and in fact some
of the measures we introduced
you know which seemed a little illogical
to a lot of people we introduced very
late
we introduced a lockdown which was just
a very crude measure to stop anyone from
seeing anyone
stopping the virus from having fuel and
then once the lake case numbers were low
we've released lockdown and we're meant
to be doing track and trace very well
what's very clear is that we're not
doing track and trace very well
and that's intimately linked to the
privatization and outsourcing of all
these
services actually there are two kind of
bodies performing track and traits at
the moment as
i mentioned previously one of the shows
it was circo circo is a private company
who run prison contracts and
hospital catering programs but also
various other services
they're a logistics company who will
accept money
large contracts from the government and
then employ people to do the job they
don't have any particular experience of
track or trace in a pandemic
but that didn't stop them from bidding
any more than many other companies had
no experience of providing ppe
they have so far been giving 208 million
they've
employed 27 000 people those 27 000
people
during the 12 weeks in which they've
been employed have on average
uh george contacted two people
each there's two people each uh so it's
an incredibly low number
and it works out at about just half the
numbers
of contacts that they need to have
traced to really
have effective sites of the virus so
it's a straightforward thing we don't
yet have a vaccine that works
um you know i understand why people are
kind of bored with this story to extend
there are other things that are killing
more poverty kills
30 40 million people a year 12 13
million children a year
but kovid comes on top of all that on
top of it yeah exactly
already dying this is yeah this is on
top of that
absolutely and you know it really is
showing how
poorly our health system as it's being
privatized and wound down
is able to adapt if you can if you
contrast that very poor job that serco
have done has been criticized by allison
pollock has been criticized by
independent sage i think very
effectively um and we'll come back a
little bit in independent stage and
the policies they're putting forward as
how we go forward um but
if you contrast that to actually the
nhs's own staff
to the extent that you know we have
still a local health teams of public
health england in place
they've been under strong threats strong
cuts
for a long period of time but they on
the other hand have traced far
greater numbers so about 140 000 people
they've traced
and they're considered more complex
cases in the community whereas circo
simply
employs someone who pick up the phone
and they're very ineffective because if
people don't pick up the phone they've
got no other way of pursuing
those contacts the local health teams
can visit houses
can speak to people can win their trust
can make them understand that they're
not there as a sinister third party but
simply
trying to help the community's health in
the same way that district nurse might
visit us if we come out of hospital and
need a wound changing so
there's a system of rapport and they're
able to trace people
and actually question them sit down and
help them fill in the answers who are
the people who've been in contact who
could you infect it people do generally
want to help
and they have contacted unbelievably
about 99
of their targets so you know and yet
circo the contract's coming up for
newell and they're scheduled to get
another 400 million i think it's very
likely they will get that
precisely because we've seen again and
again that is the favored option
of our government so you know our
numbers are lower i think if you look
over the last week
372 people if you have died
there may be more to come and of course
those numbers are relatively low but
372 people is not really a small number
george and this is
as again independent stage pull down
this should be the easiest time to
control the virus people are not at
school people are not at university
more people are on holiday uh the
weather is such that people are outside
enjoying themselves and not in crowded
spaces so
all of the conditions are in our favor
and yet it's been pointed out that
just as we said last week it's been
popularly recognized in in the press
this week that the r rates
pretty much across the board are
creeping back towards the one and
some places exceeding one so in other
words the numbers and infections are
increasing
though the numbers of deaths are down
the numbers of test positive crews and
cases are increasing again
over over a thousand towards a thousand
one hundred
over the last 24 hours per day and
that's
the numbers test proven based on
antibody results as we said last week
his life could be actually three or four
times
that perhaps four four and a half
thousand people getting the virus a day
at this one it should be the easiest
time to control and therefore that's led
to a whole you know a lot of
renewed discussion about what are the
things that should be opening and what
are the things that should be closing
and just how effective it is to let it
run rampant in the community and then
shut everything down again and you know
doing it piecemeal here and there
of course it means that there's very
mixed messages people are fed up of
quite a long sacrifice of several months
that they've been effectively putting
their lives on hold they're told that
that's why the economy has been
tanking though actually there's been a
very severe systemic crisis of
capitalism as i think you've had
professor wolf on your show and pointed
out quite well this is not just
coronavirus this is
a problem inherent in our economic
system
which is compounded by coronavirus but
not caused by it and of course
desperate to you know get the economy
going again
but in the process um have taken the
foot off the brakes and without doing
the simple public health things that
really can mean
like vietnam has like you know new
zealand has as of course
china did very early on and made it you
know its
results published to the world and told
us really gave us a blueprint of how to
approach this correctly
um we're not we're not doing those
things george and so it's it's
perhaps boring that the story knocks on
and on and on
a it's not all uh boring at least not as
you
uh uh comment on it uh last point
doctor if cases are going up
uh again as they are but deaths are
going down does that mean the virus
is running out of toxicity
that is not as deadly as it was
or another reason uh well to me it
indicates that while
we also see that lag so someone's
infected and
the virus runs of quite a long course so
though it can manifest symptoms soon
can take two or three weeks to show
symptoms and the and the illness if
people
who are in intensive care some of them
as for example uh
the poet michael rosen or author you
know
run for two or three months so the
deaths there's a long lag
between when the infections are so what
it probably means is that
if infections start going up then i'm
afraid in a number of weeks
we will start to see that the deaths
stop falling and and
the trend is reversed of course it may
be
that the most vulnerable people
are now more effectively isolated
certainly our testing capacity has
increased
though again privatized contracted out
and not well coordinated
so it's possible that the the death rate
is lower but we've got no strong
evidence as to why that would be so it's
likely to be the case that if the r rate
starts going up the number of cases
start going up i'm afraid to say that
the number of people who succumb to the
virus will also go up in a number of
weeks george
dr ranjit thank you and we'll see you
next week because this
isn't going away anytime soon thank you
again for your help now what should i
name my new child to my astonishment uh
persephone which i'd
genuinely never heard of before is doing
rather well
persephone 38 maggie 39
as those of a certain ash and nicola
23 you can vote now on
my twitter feed here's a call from
coventry
stefan stefan in coventry on beirut
go ahead sir yeah good evening george um
congratulations on the birth of your
newborn
thank you so much and thank you for
coming on tonight after 48 hours without
sleep it's much appreciated i haven't
slept
but i'm i'm i'm running on t
yeah yeah i'm glad you're not so tired
just speaking like joe biden yeah but um
now it's great to yeah
it's great that you've made it tonight
thank you yeah just it really saddened
me to see
um lebanon and what happened in the
deaths it's it's traumatic it just takes
me back to sort of late 70s my early
adult years in the 80s where all i saw
was um
yeah tragedy in beirut bombings by
israeli jets
um you know just uh terrorists you know
bombings
it was all every time you switch the
news on there's something bad happening
in
ridge i really feel for the people over
there it's just
um i don't know it's just tragic i don't
know what's happened you know i say i
saw
um ramya early on talking about it and
i'm glad she survived um
but yeah i'll just my heart goes
it's very unlucky uh for lebanon
uh it uh through no fault of its own
had to accommodate hundreds of thousands
it's a very small place
hundreds or thousands of palestinian
refugees
in 1948 then again in 1970 after
uh the the events in in jordan
uh and then again intermittently uh
through the decades
and then when the war against syria
began
uh had to absorb hundreds of thousands
of syrian refugees
this in a very small and poor country
a country without industry of its own
without significant agriculture
of its own a place where arabs
who did have wealth from iraq from
the gulf uh used to come and
buy property and deposit money and have
holidays
and so on all of which is now at an end
so even without this disastrous
explosion lebanon was in a very very
serious situation
and now yes god knows uh what will
happen the only thing
that makes me think they'll come out of
it is they've come out of so much
before the liberties are quite an
extraordinary people i tell you
they are and that's the point i was
going to make that the fact that they've
survived so much in the past i'm sure
they'll come out of this stronger even
more and um yeah it's it's just
yeah it's just remarkable the resilience
of the people over there that they think
that i know there's a lot of trouble
going on the note
it does resemble hong kong but it's um
you know well
there's going to be any of those three
let's hope it's hong kong and not the
other two oh hong kong we can live with
two of my children
are half lebanese uh and as i said i
entered
lebanon well over 40 years ago and
it took me into the arab world which
uh has been an absorbing interest of
mine for
well over half of my life so it's very
important
yeah it does yeah grab your personal
affection in your heart as well george
um yeah there's another point to make to
the guy i phoned up to get on this show
is um
how much more of watching rt and one of
the reasons behind that
is the fact that when they have guests
on like yourself or people with other
opposite views they actually let me
speak yeah exactly
you know stefan i i'm on
seven days a week and i write a column
nobody has ever not ever in the nearly
10 years i've been working here
10 years has ever said to me
that i shouldn't say something or i
should say something
that would never happen at the bbc or
sky stefan
oh no what i've watched some of you all
this stuff on there and i've seen you
when you have been on in the past and i
think well
just let the man speak with you and it's
not
you know it's not just yourself it's
anybody who's if you go on these shows
and then it's like the cargo board
but rick sanchez showed absolutely
brilliant manila
all of them he had the impressive all
rachel blendings on today they were
wonderful
and rachel uh rachel's uh a rising star
stefan
rachel definitely you're going to
remember later
that you first saw her on here and on rt
america stefan
thanks for the lovely call i appreciate
it
uh you've still got time to call or 2077
two five 982-255 or in the us zero zero
one
seven five seven seven four four four
four
eight zero raymond is in london on
lebanon
go ahead raymond hello george um first
let me congratulate
you and your wife thank you fantastic
it's such an honor isn't it to ever
maybe whether it's
the first one yeah all the sticks
right um whatever happened george no i'm
not well reading the subject i'll follow
you
on a number of platforms but whatever
happened to the arab league
yes the arabs have a league as i always
say
if they do it's a vauxhall conference
league raymond not the premiership
yeah well they need to have an aeroplake
again with syria
and all the rest of the countries that
stand together against these
oppressions because someone somewhere
is trying to unstabilize the lebanon
like they entertain iraq like they
unstabilize syria
nothing because the uh the arabs
are completely divided there are people
trying to destabilize them and there
have been
devastating wars against arab countries
from israel from america from britain
from france and others
in the case of libya but the arabs are
pretty good at
murdering themselves murdering each
other
and are remarkably easily
set to uh set to
each other's throat uh for the purpose
of keeping them divided
uh so that they will be weak so that
they can be robbed
there's no point in beating about the
bush here
uh arabs taiwan arabs have agency
uh they could decide not to murder each
other uh they could have decided
that whether america wanted the
overthrow of bashar
or not they were not going to go along
with it
whether the government of saddam hussein
was bad
or not they were not going to
collaborate
with the british and american
governments to invade and occupy it
they could have decided whatever they
thought about
colonel gaddafi replacing him with isis
and al qaeda
was definitely not a step forward and so
on so the point raymond is
this that the arabs are divided and weak
the west wants to keep them divided and
weak
for a hundred years they have been
divided
and weak and the west was very happy
uh for that to be so and arranged things
so that it was more likely uh to be
so last word to you raymond thank you
very much soldier
it is in fact the college of knowledge
brother
thank you so much thank you my dear
friend uh
i've got three pages of baby names
stacy says i love persephone well that's
um dr angie and stacy both loved
persephone it's growing on me
uh sandy says grace because i'm sure
she'll have it and humpty dumpty says
galen that's mischievous alejandro says
a wise man
lets his wife decide well actually i
picked all of my children's names and
all of them were good pics
i think and uh their mothers agree
uh twitter user says georgette of course
and leo says i'm sorry but i can't get
behind any of those
maybe something like sky
warm leo warm and paul says just tuned
in
baby name suggestion alaska that's a
nice one actually
and france says i believe the explosion
in beirut was accidental only because
a fire preceded it which triggered the
nitrate
but an inquiry may establish its
provenance
and on facebook phil says i didn't know
george was old enough to have children
yet and jazz says in a few months we'll
start hearing the effects on people
from the ammonium nitrate from breathing
problems respiratory infect
infections etc and james says
bojo should resign he did an awful job
and on twitter claire says loving the
new labour ad that played at the last
break
hilarious and true sadly
i didn't actually hear it but here's
that was the week
uh this is where i look at the seven
days in history
which changed our world for good and bad
it was on this day
this day in 1945 that the united states
dropped the second
atomic bomb called fat man on nagasaki
japan destroying part of the city and
killing
an estimated 50 000 people just like
that
in 1965 singapore separated from the
federation
of malaysia and gained its independence
and in 1974 richard nixon resigned
as president of the united states over
the watergate break-in scandal
and vice president gerald ford was sworn
in to take his place
as the 38th u.s president in 1969
the actress sharon tate was found
brutally murdered
in her l.a home along with three high
society friends
and a fifth victim in january 1971
charles manson and three of his
followers susan atkin
patricia krenwinkel and leslie van
houten
were convicted of the tate la bianca
murders after the longest murder trial
in us history
in 1971 the prime minister of northern
ireland brian faulkner
introduced a new law giving the
authorities the power
to indefinitely detain suspected
terrorists without trial
more than 300 suspects were detained
in a series of dawn raids two days later
in 2003 britain recorded
its hottest day ever what like hotter
than today
as the temperature soared to 38.1
that's a hundred point six degrees
fahrenheit in
old money that was in graves end in kent
i don't know what it reached in london
today but it was pretty close to that i
can tell you
and on the 12th of august 1964
one of the so-called great train robbers
escaped from
winston green prison in birmingham
charlie wilson
then aged 32 was apparently freed by a
gang of three men
who broke into the jail in the early
hours of the morning
wilson went on the run for four years
and was finally recaptured in canada
and returned to jail in the uk where he
served out the rest of his sentence
he then moved to the costa del sol in
spain
of course where he is alleged to have
become involved in drug dealing
and was shot dead by a hitman on the
23rd of april 1990
as he relaxed by his swimming pool by
the way a big thanks to my friends in
the
prison officers association for their
very very kind
greetings and uh congratulations good
wishes
uh on the birth of my latest child the
journalist at the center of the
controversy
surrounding the death of weapons expert
dr david kelly
on the same day in 2003 admitted that
his language
wasn't perfect when he reported the
government had
sexed up its weapons dossier on
iraq of course it wasn't perfect it was
a grotesque understatement
andrew gilligan the aforementioned
defense correspondent of the bbc
radio 4 today program was giving
evidence to the hutton
inquiry on its second day hutton
absorbed the government
of any kind of dishonorable underhand
or duplicitous strategy in the leaking
of dr kelly's name to the press
well you'll find out in my forthcoming
film
just how far off beam the late
justice hutton was in that case
on the 13th of august 1961 troops in
east germany sealed off the border
between east and west berlin shutting
off the escape route
for thousands of refugees from the east
it says here within days troops began
replacing the barbed wire with concrete
blocks
and the wall became a permanent
structure it was of course the berlin
wall
which eventually reached nearly 12 feet
high and 66
miles long on the same day in 1966
china announced plans for a new leap
forward after the first meeting in four
years
of the communist party's central
committee
and the so-called cultural revolution
heralded a dramatic
purge of mao's rivals on
august the 14th in 1969
the british government sent troops into
northern ireland
in what it said was a limited operation
to restore
law and order the army's warm welcome
was short-lived
as was the british in british
government's intention
to pull out the troops within days and
finally
on the 15th of august 1945
japan surrendered unconditionally to the
allies
after almost six years of war the allies
had delivered japan
an ultimatum to surrender on the 28th
of july when this was ignored the u.s
dropped the two atomic bombs on
hiroshima
6th august and nagasaki 9th
august that was the week that was in all
of our histories okay coming up
in the next 20 minutes exclusive photos
of my new child i held them back so that
the mother of all talk shows audience
would be the first to see them a million
people
a million people received the
birth notice that i put out on twitter
1.1
million impressions 10 and a half
thousand likes 1200
1500 comments absolutely extraordinary
so
i do know that there is interest in the
baby and she's coming up
shortly but you can still vote for
persephone or maggie
be back in a second
[Music]
tune in every thursday to loud and clear
with brian becker for a regular segment
called
criminal injustice about the most
egregious conduct of our courts
and how justice is denied to so many
people in this country
tune in to loud and clear this thursday
and every thursday for thorough and
independent analysis of our criminal
injustice system
[Music]
stop banging on the toilet door amber
stop banging on the toilet door
you're gonna frighten the pilot anyway
i'll
uh i'll talk to you when we land
although that could take a considerable
amount of
[Music]
breaking news expert analysis and
exclusive stories
all in one place
radio sputnik telling the untold
global higher education with one of the
world's best known iconoclasts
the mother of all talk shows with george
galloway
[Music]
time is running so let's get as many
calls in
as we can william is in london on prince
andrew
go ahead william hello there nice to
speak to you
thank you for having me on welcome um
yeah i
i'm calling in a reaction actually to an
earlier caller who was calling about the
arms
um trading perhaps of the maxwell family
in general yeah i think he might have
been getting confused he said that
epstein was involved in arms trading but
i i have not seen any report of that
yeah well i just wanted to bring perhaps
to the table the um
cable from wikileaks regarding prince
andrews
in fact um role in trade and what sort
of views and
affairs he may have had with it excuse
me
within the um trading in that area
yeah go ahead yeah go ahead remind us
remind us
well we know in in 2010 his
relationships with sort of kyrgyzstan
and kazakhstan were
a little bit promiscuous to say the
least and and then the cable came out
saying that he was sort of
condoning bribery and so on and so forth
from
the bae and and and the cable between
himself and america
the the diplomatic cable which went
through there which the guardian public
published um i find that very
very interesting i think you know i
think it's important to remember that
time
at this time and with what we see going
on you know
yeah i don't know i don't quite know why
he
uh has had apparent money troubles
all of his life he is the queen's son
uh he used to get anyway
a handsome son uh most things
like castles and so on are provided to
him uh
and yet he seems to have had a constant
need
uh to get down and dirty uh doing
business
uh with some rum some rum
characters yeah i mean the duchy of
lancaster provides
the queen with a very very substantial
sum of money
and he he he gets an allowance so why he
has to do
business in kyrgyzstan i have no idea
yeah yeah well that's that's um you know
going back to something you said before
that you'd experienced in the house
apartment very very unsavory experience
to say the least at the very least
um i i what brought me such attention in
this particular area was that
that um i had been through a certain
sort of relationship with
russia a partner of mine i was
sponsoring to bring to from russia to
the uk and we went to
hell on earth you know we went i was
accused of being a spy in the high court
by the uk ba
um for absolutely no reason but during
that time obviously i i
needed and big shout out here to julian
assange please because
he really helped me during that time and
it's very nice to be able to say that
but during that i was in russia and i
had you know i won't go
go into it here but uh really some very
odd um
communications with people you know
relating to sort of
uh blood diamonds things like that you
know
conflict diamonds i think it's all very
relevant and i and i
again julian sands you know he brought
all that to the table and i i really
would just like to remember him you know
hot tip
to julian assange william thanks for the
call first time caller
uh don't be a stranger michael is in
gothenburg
go ahead michael okay i just wanted to
weigh
in on the blast in beirut
i have no specific information but
i just would encourage people not to
conspiracy theorized too much uh i do
know about
the russian vessel that was delivering
uh aluminum nitrate to and it was
actually on its way together
it wasn't russian it was ukrainian it
was registered was ukrainian yeah
it was an important difference
yes yes god and it was on its way
from uh moldova which is of course a
prime maritime nation
right and it was going to travel further
to to mozambique was it not
yeah there was there's some doubt as to
whether it was uh going to africa
uh or whether it was going to uh the
wahhabist uh rebels in syria
there's doubt about it okay
yeah yeah yeah see and that and now
i could say i don't want to uh float
conspiracy theories now an interesting
thing about the
term conspiracy theory is that that
phrase was
itself minted uh by the cia
to discourage people from uh
to make people seem ridiculous for
questioning
uh the the motives of the cia
is that correct yeah yeah you're
absolutely right and
of course there have been plenty of
conspiracies
uh some of the biggest events uh in our
time
michael have been conspiracies but that
doesn't
mean that everything is a conspiracy
correct correct and the conspiracy
theory can is
is either true or it's false yeah so
it's nothing
to uh yeah if it looks like a duck walks
like a duck and quacks like a duck
it's probably a duck thank you thank you
yes i'm i'm active i just wanted to you
know put this out there i'm active
as a member of the uh in swedish it's
called
udar for israelis palestinians freyja
the jews for the jews
for a israeli palestinian peace
and so we are working in here in
gothenburg to
you know promote uh public opinion you
know where
the palestinian rights of the you know
the rights of the palestinian people are
not to be overlooked in any way shape or
form
and uh israel is you know just
way out of line and it's got to be
reigned in
and i don't know where to begin with
that but no well no time alas uh
now on this show but uh a big
shout out to all friends in denmark in
gothenburg and to the jewish voices for
palestinian rights
in particular i'm very grateful i think
yeah last word mike i think i think it's
just so important
uh for us as jews to show that we are
not going down this zionist uh
propaganda
path and to vilify people you know
an entire people uh just that just
doesn't make any sense
amen amen thank you michael god bless
you
sam is in west yorkshire uh on father's
go ahead sam
uh hi george can you hear me yes very
well go ahead
yeah i just want to say i want to tell
all the men out there
all the fathers that you don't have to
do anything wrong you don't have to be
abusive or you don't have to uh um
do anything illegal once you've split up
with your ex
she can cut you out of your children's
lives forever i spent two years
and even if you're not i'll be from
going from living with them
uh 24 hours a day to
contact uh on a tuesday at six o'clock
handed back eight o'clock that was me
george
uh when we split up initially the
children was living with me i mean she
was having mental problems
so so we agreed that the children would
live with me until a year they lived
with me
and then when she decided that she
wanted the children back in their lives
all she had to do
was to go to court and and the car did
not rule in her favor in the beginning
so eventually
she started making um allegations of
domestic and sexual abuse and then all
of a sudden i was
completely out of the children's lives
the the police turned up at my house
at one o'clock in the morning they took
the kids i i had no idea that this was
going on this happened overnight and
then i spent the
uh the i spent two what two years
fighting uh first the allegations which
were unproven
i i don't have a criminal record i i've
never broken the law i've never been in
court
i never i i never even raised my voice
at the children george
but within all of us and she makes these
allegations and and i have not seen the
kids in 13 years
oh yeah i spent two weeks flattening in
court i i exhausted all my savings
i i quit my job so i could spend a full
time on this evil case
and then and then after i run out of
money i couldn't afford to to go to
court anymore
and i haven't seen my kids in 13 years
heartbreaking uh sam i'm very sorry to
hear that
uh but the hour as such i really can't
go into it any further
i need to move on nikki is in paris
on coronavirus the pandemic nikki
welcome
hi george and congratulations from me
as well on our new little comrade thank
you stephanie is greek by the way she
was the daughter of dimitra
the goddess of agriculture a very
important
uh very important
very uneducated and ignorant of me
uh not to have heard of her and the name
is growing on me
i don't think it will grow on my wife
but she don't have to spell it all her
life exactly that's the problem
i like short names nikki short names
that the chinese can say easily these
are
these are my uh important rubrics of
course they've got to have
a meaning and so on but short yeah that
the chinese can say because i figure
by the time my children grow up well the
chinese are going to be the most
important
country in the world anyway go ahead go
ahead
okay so um yeah i wanted to ask you
about what you as george would uh do
exactly to handle pandemic socially
and economically uh you know what is the
best way
you know to handle i wouldn't have i
wouldn't have started
from here being half an irishman i'm
allowed to
say that as the irishman apocryphally
did when asked the way to dublin
uh the the only way to handle this
is in uh draconian
uh even authoritari or authoritarian way
if you're new zealand uh with the
sparse population widely flung
and high levels of education
and health services you can do it a
different way but the
reason that china which
would easily given the intensely
densely populated areas of china
did not become a complete catastrophe is
because
china acted as its system
allowed it to do in an extremely
authoritarian manner therefore it
literally when they said lock down they
don't mean a lockdown
that you still get on the bus or you
still go into
work on the underground lockdown is
locked down in china means that you
simply cannot go
anywhere that you must stay in your
house
that you will be arrested if you come
out of your house
that's the kind of decisive
state centralized state
action that china took and that's what
stopped
at the catastrophe that china would
otherwise
have been now of course south korea
which is also by the way relatively
speaking
for a western oriented capitalist
country quite authoritarian quite
centrally
strong as a state power
uh did something of the same but i think
that china and vietnam
dealt with this best and they did so
by taking draconian and even
authoritarian
action right at the beginning nikki last
word
uh i agree but they their socialist
systems the thing is
how does one do the draconian thing
under a capitalist system where a worker
has a
choice of dying of poverty or dying of
the virus
right so well that's the superiority of
the
socialist system so far as
i and i infer you uh
are concerned uh we should have done
as much as we could like
china and south korea as long as
our system was able to we should have
gone down
uh that road i've got to go nikki
because nicola in swindon wants to talk
about the same subject
nicola go ahead good evening to you
georgian congratulations on the birth of
your daughter
thank you so much i do hope you picked
the names of nicola
after all it's a it's a great name
wonderful name
it is a wonderful name um but we're in
ireland george we should have closed the
airports and the porch way back at the
beginning of the year
we allowed millions of people to fly in
here
including from the most affected places
yes millions in and out and it's been
spread
when you've got a world pandemic you
don't go
zooming around the world spreading it
from one place to another which is what
people have done
quite innocently some of them but you
know uh i'm sure all of them
nobody wants to spread them
we should have really locked down nicola
really locked down
nobody goes out nobody goes to work
nobody moves around nobody flies in here
we are an island after all we could
actually have protected ourselves
in that way so easy so easy to have done
uh and the numbers the reason i've been
told that the numbers are increasing now
is because we are actually testing
people and finding people
with the virus who don't have any
symptoms whereas at the height of the
virus
they weren't testing because they didn't
want even more people
coming to the hospital whereas now we
are actually looking for it
rather than it just appeared nicola
given my age and given that my wife was
pregnant until yesterday
why were we never tested why would we
never offer the test
who got tested if not us i do not know i
was nearly tested i was driving along
and some sort of left out and went and
waved me into the testing center and i
was actually just trying to get home for
my dinner
but i nearly only got tested by mistake
it just always struck me as funny why
somebody of my age
uh with uh with a pregnant wife and many
small children
i would have thought i was high on the
list to get a test but i was never with
it
i was never able to get one i would have
thought so as well
but uh i i it how this government
works in mysterious ways i will never
understand it
exactly thanks nicholas nice to talk to
you uh what name
should i choose for my new child a
nikola
24 up one uh b
maggie 37 down two
and c persephone 39
down one so who would have thought that
the most
popular suggestion would have been
persephone
who we now know is a figure of classical
uh importance um it is it did grow on me
and i'm sorry for all the people
who sent in beautiful name suggestions
that i simply haven't had time uh to
reach uh um i'm really grateful to you
for going to
all that uh trouble now
uh the poll is closed 686 of you
uh voted uh persephone won
but the child will actually be called
if you want to write this down because
it's slightly complicated
her first name is auburn like the
scottish uh beautiful little scottish
town auburn with the fada going
to the left at the top of the o obam
obam amaria
a-m-a-r-i-a
oban amariah galloway and there she is
my latest little darling and there she
is
there's a family picture uh
taken earlier today and this is gayatri
in
it was a home bath this is our in the
pool
uh we rented uh a pool
in the bottom of the bed two wonderful
totally wonderful
oh my goodness congratulations from the
guys behind the glass
thank you
thanks so much ron uh that's very
touching thank you
so she gave birth in this pool
uh with two wonderful uh midwives
i'm totally wonderful i mean it always
amazes me when i have close contact with
uh national health service uh people
how dedicated they are i mean they'd get
their wages
whether they were really conscientious
and dedicated or not
it's truly a vocation these two women
really cared that this baby should be
born
healthily uh it was very grueling as i
say i'm over it now
but my poor wife is uh
still very tired and the baby is two
but there she is with her brother and
sister
so it's perfect symmetry actually uh by
the grace of god i have six
children three boys and three girls
isn't that perfect i'm so blessed
i thank god for all of my blessings
and i thank you for all of the good
wishes
that you have been sending uh
me by all platforms over the last
few days and thank you to my dear
friends who knew
that my friends through their
knew how to pick flowers thank you very
much for
watching for listening it's been
marvelous for me
i hope it was for you and if it was come
back next week
at the same time in the same place
and join me again for the mother of all
talk shows
i'm going home now for another sleepless
night
hope it didn't show too much
[Music]
you